[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
anything
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
hello
earlier
that's what's up 41 in the chat we're
just waiting man we're chilling right
now we got
will be hood in the realm we're getting
more comfortable and acquainted you know
what i'm saying we get deceptives the
chalices
moving right now we're just waiting on
solving king y'all we will be back
good to see y'all filing in and
hopefully y'all like the little music
that uh
got going while y'all wait so see you in
a bit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
ah
[Music]
to the iron lords podcast and the lords
of gaming.net
episode number 150 oh damn cat daddy
with a cold oh
y'all better get it it is another
glorious city
and we're back at the round table of the
lord's day i'm extremely excited about
our special guest
and we've got xbox series x tech reveal
ps5 deep dive with mark
cerny doom eternal and animal crossing
to discuss
so we gonna get right into it i want to
introduce a lord who steady rise as a
content creator
has truly been a sight to behold whether
it be his welcoming and charitable
nature to the gaming community
or his passion for multi-platform games
this lord's focus on the humor in gaming
yet is never afraid to clap back at
those who are disrespectful
introducing the created host of gaming
behind the box
the horror cats in the wilmie hood
youtube channel
gaming's mouth of the south one of the
leaders of the fork nation
and by far the most hilarious memes
you'll ever come across
on twitter live from wilmington north
carolina
and making his debut into the realm of
the lords
my man lord will be hood how you doing
sir
jesus what an intro and whoa there
is man and white gonna pop up in my
front door now with a chopper
i am honored uh honestly this was the
first podcast i
ever listened to involving wow wow so
it is a huge honor to be here much
appreciate so you just can't
i gotta ask this this is this is unique
so you came across the uh
the iop randomly how did you it was just
one a suggested video like how did you
come across the content just curious
um years ago i was a admin for a
giant uh gaming group on facebook we had
like 60
000 members and somebody on the
on the group had to go post one of your
videos
and just out of curiosity because i mean
when you when you
admit any type of facebook group you get
people trying to post all kinds of crazy
[ __ ]
and we check everything i got to ask the
language or the lord today
i gotta ask we check every link you know
to be posted
and it was a link to your channel
wow so i i watched it and i continued to
watch it at that point i was like
geez i don't remember what year i'm
getting old
[Laughter]
you know i would sit and chat just with
you guys or play you in the background
are you yo this is so cool i've never
like
is isn't it like surreal kick like it's
all like the hair story like that like
because
just one of those things like for for a
long while you have like this you have
this small group of people that you know
are like
or your fans and you're there every week
and you don't really see how that
kind of propagates out and little by
little you start sending more people in
and you're like where'd you come from
how did you
hear about us it's so crazy man that's
crazy to me like that feels yeah
they can't hear me okay just out of
curiosity put in the chat how you came
across iop i'm kind of kidding
yeah kind of curious because like it
really like it feels good to hear
stories like that because obviously
for me it still feels like we're still
new in a way right
how do i feel like yeah well i told you
the story about yesterday
i went to go pick up a statue from a
dude because he's in my stature group
and he posted something and
you know we're texting back and forth
but my picture on facebook is not my
face i'm sorry i gotta stop you for a
second so other zinc is saying we are
low i kind of hear everything low in my
headphones too they're saying we're
overall low we're overall low so add
turns
i could blame him i turned it off name
addict i'm doing
[Music]
like i need more feedback uh you know no
offense to the one person we need to
know it's multiple people that's not
live streaming
you know what i'm saying philly eagles
said we would guest on rdx that's how
you heard us shroom kingdom in a circle
you know what i'm saying titan boom
charles boom okay different places
qw vampire bull stick de niro says um he
hears us fine other ziggs says addict is
perfect
so atticus or attic is perfect but
it's gucci i go
to go pick
and he's like when i get there because i
call him on the phone first i'm like yo
i'm downstairs
so he that's the first time we talked on
the phone
he was like okay okay i'm coming
downstairs what car you driving so you
know i'm driving a black suburb in the
big jungle
so um he comes outside and he has a
statue and he's like i knew it
i knew it was you i knew it was you oh
my god i watch your joints i watch the
videos
kos wow he went into
telling me about uh via kos and he was
like yo yo here's a hundred dollars back
yeah man yo you just just yo just give
me a shout out on your joints
oh my god i'm like it was bugging me out
for one i'm like okay i'm a regular dude
look at it look at kid smooth man
stories that would be about destiny
podcasts he wanted to do i was like okay
sounds like boring stuff yo it's crazy
shout out to a lot of people um
i'm seeing already x today i'm seeing
boom in there um it looks like
everybody's hearing us good oh shout out
to mostly martinez you're from last
wordpocket you're an iop from
i forgot about when we did that remember
when we had that planet xbox
and iop collaboration someone else said
rdx in rdp
about ilv this is dope that's just yo
mojo said he showed up to hate on
destiny and he never left
my brother that makes sense that makes
sense that makes sense shout out to
multiple
i know he's going through it right now
he's on the mend that is what's up man
so like we're going to get these
things going we have a super chat from
kid oh please get it please get it
let me push the little button so uh two
dollar super chat from
uh kid smooth at wilmy hood buy me
condemned criminal origins i cannot
believe
you came on our podcast and super chat
of two dollars
to ask another man to buy you okay
at least he wasn't asking me to pay for
his wife's bluebeam plans
oh wow shout out to dizzy the chat
playback gaming you already know this
you know the vibes
you know the origins of this that's
what's so he took it back to pvg
then we got a lot of stuff to go though
but real quickly all will be you all in
your room what have you been playing sir
what have you been playing
doom i know that's a surprise
playing doom eternal when i'm not
working and that's the bad part with
everything going on in the world
yeah we have been really busy that's
what's up that's what's up man you
already know
and of course you already know we got
the four horsemen of gaming those
original lords of the realm
fully back together at the round table
my co-host with the coal most
my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror
lord of reviews and the how of the young
wolf
my man lord addict how are we doing sir
so
we're doing very fantastic so i've had a
very inlightful week i actually beat
infamous
uh i never beat that game when it came
out uh at the
beginning of the gin i actually never
finished that game i started it
but then dropped it for some other i
don't know what it was
and i'm actually playing persona 5 again
so it's it you know it's it's a quaranti
kind of week so i got to play the
quarantine games the
the the ps4 island games no no
no no and uh you were doing some uh what
else anything else besides that
uh no not really you know i've been
playing not that much destiny here
lately but we got a five dollar super
chat wow
from smitty smith you just don't know
how the impact that the iron lures
podcast has it really has made a
different
salute thank you brother that means a
lot that means a lot for real brother
that's what's up attic and of course
returning
my brother our most technical gaming
lord the solo gamer who lives with a
single-player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus mr offline
profile illuminati and lord patreon of
the iron bank
my man lord sovereign how we doing sir
doing all right man doing all right uh i
gotta i have to echo smithy smith
sentiments man like
i need this today i need to be around my
peoples my brothers today you know it's
been
it's been a tough week a lot of
craziness uh just like when we said uh
kind of been on the front lines of this
so kind of going out every single day
not front lines like you know dealing
with patients and stuff like that but
sort of being out there and
having to be out there um and it it new
york city is a little crazy now and it's
only i am less crazier i am legend right
now
they're calling us right now so i we
need to drew back because i needed to
get your knees in the box
oh my god no sympathy earlier
i got to say this dizzy i love you but
don't help me bro you're not helping me
and then
so he says oh i think we hold the knees
and i'm like no we don't
getting it wrong and then you put the
battery in his back
and then he comes out i'm like oh here
we
go
while we got that
definitely gonna allow you to just wait
until it comes out because like we said
when he thought it comes out
you know he holds it up i want the knees
when i see
the original let me as i have to
reiterate yet again
listen when you when you go to do your
back compact it's going to charge you
that's that's that's my you're going to
charge you're going to be ten games that
are actually backing back
yeah you're gonna get three five games
for the back compact every time we say
it's gonna get lower
as it goes by does it catch mine
so do all the matters i know you've been
on the front line so yeah you have a lot
going on you know what i'm saying so
obviously we're concerned about you so
i'm glad you are here and
feeling good sounding good so that's
good yeah but uh what what are you
playing sir
have you got a chance to play much
anything you know what i've been playing
your topic hell yeah hell on earth
rip and tear until it is done baby
doom oh that's what i've been playing
we'll get into that
shout out to face 23 bkny with the 10
super chat congratulations on the power
narrative who knows what big or minimal
impact it will have compared to
playstation 5.
here's a question if both systems are
doing native 4k
60 what will differentiate that oh they
going in
early face with that you want me to
answer that
okay well i can tell you when that
bottleneck popped
your throat in that playstation 5.
you're going to figure out what really
happened when you try to do 4k six for
me oh my god
damn it's an unstable box i don't like
it
it's unstable they overclocked it you
know it's like taking a hugo
and putting a supercharger in the middle
so you're trying to get that hugo to go
really fast where
you just brought a nice stable uh
powerful vehicle see it's like me and my
suburban and you trying to race me with
that supercharged hugo
you gonna get down the block are you
going to get down the block in flames or
you can get down to black regularly
so just just just to clear what you just
said
you're saying that they got they got the
ride that's going to blow up midway
through the race
i everybody named mom's knowledge they
trying to get us a
a 4-5 dude to dunk a basketball
right now he might be able to mugsy bowl
it but
one of those things he's going to
real quick i finally stopped frauding
and i picked up
vr i picked up the oculus quest because
i'm
not wires now i'm not about if you put
it down in the same
breath it took you to hook it listen
well let me let me speak with somebody
who hasn't done
any of it yet right so i like i'm coming
in i'm usually
with king on the front lines when it
comes to getting this stuff and when it
came to view i was like
so i just finally did it because i
wanted to play half-life alex
now this is my issue which i'm having
trouble with right now and i think i
might be screwed in that regard
i'm thinking my my my pc which is a
laptop now i don't have a tower anymore
has the appropriate specs to be able to
connect with the new oculus link so
actually connecting the oculus quest to
the
to the laptop to play um regular steam
vr games as well as regular oculus games
so apparently
it's a power supply thing like obviously
the power supply on the laptop is not
the same so i might be screwed in that
regard so no half-life alex but
yeah there might be some some hope for
me because there is some sort of thing
called
a side quest where you side load you can
side load stuff to actually stream it
over 5g
yeah to the headset so i'm going to try
that if that doesn't work then
i i spent you know 400 bucks on it
you must have risen for half-life alex
he said you must have risen that's what
he said
it did shout out oh let me see oh shout
out to you elliot oh i see my boy undead
in the chat yo salute the undead man i
know he was feeling well earlier so it's
good to see him in here
elias stromith um he said i love how
soon it's gonna be a pretty price spicy
day so many frauds on twitter streets on
both sides
people need to play more doom and next
xbox game pass stop ponying and biting
all around i feel like
with the two dollar super chat today i
will be reading from the good book
we gonna bring the scripture i have no
idea i'm about to set
these dudes
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this
aka the access gamer who
the lord of combat sports king of the
statues there's nothing less than that
premium experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved lord king how are we doing sir
we're doing fantastic but
but behold but hold on we haven't did
this
[Music]
[Music]
you know the funniest thing about that
was
cognito almost spent whatever's in that
car that come
out he looked at it when he started
dancing
because i know he really a fool
all right so what i've been playing this
week um let me get a who did that for
you
oh let's do it again game pass strikes
again
you can't do that you know that ace
combat seven
and the boy didn't pay a dime
i knew it i saw it on the screen that
summer jam screening never let me down
yet baby
let me tell you right now phil dominus
maximus spencer is
on one baby yo
the surge too i played the surge one i
finished the surge one
you know what phil said he said god
bless the surge too
thank you thank you kitten pass
put the jazz up
yo he's letting you finish the first one
and just slide you the second one just
in case you know you like the first one
you don't say
you like that shrimp barbecue it's a
more shrimp barbecue
part oh two yo
i am not gonna front yo
with this quarantine situation i'll be
quarantined anyways
new to me but this allows me actually
just
just act quarantined you know what i'm
saying like i'm
i'm acting quarantined i'm acting like
that backlog need to get roughed up a
little bit
you're punching stuff in the face like
yo the children of order
i actually almost have every character
at level 20.
damn and this is such an achievement and
um
somebody hit me on twitter and was like
yo i i love the story because it's the
best roguelike because
when you finish a little things they
just give you a little story like i seen
this dude that looked like dr doom do
some weird stuff with a sword
when it was one of the dudes dreams and
i was like yo
and it does this to me every so often
and it's just random like i'll finish
one little board and then you know i go
back to the house and just start
you know piling on to my character
giving them some more extra powers
and it'll be a cutscene and i'm like yo
this is so dope
this is absolutely yo 11 bit is probably
my studio of the year right now
i made blood
what's your thoughts on devs on twitter
third and first party saying playstation
5
ssd will be a game changer yeah man
there's a lot to talk about with that i
know we're going to get on to the
internet
when we get to that subject but yeah
we're definitely going to address that
face 23 trust me hold that thought
i got you we're going to break that down
when it's that segment but continue
[Applause]
look at that you know what happened in
the room you know what happened kids we
got tired of
not having the access to those emotes
put the shield in there man i'm gonna
put the shield in on the screen
welcome kids move to the room yo thanks
to kid
we now get an extra emoji because we
reached 10 within the last couple of
days an extra 10
so we're gonna debut a new area i know
like should we we're gonna talk about
we're already gonna talk about it for
what that is but the boy already got it
on deck
it's gonna be hilarious i'm gonna love
that one and real quick um shout out to
lady erica in the chat she said she's
loving the new
layout addict and uh smitty smith final
super chat playstation fanboys
sir my back hurts jim ryan why am i
tired of moving the goal post
the book of acts let's get him lord
i think you wanted something that's a
hard back breaking eight
you know what i'm saying you like you
know how i feel like when when
when you get down to the medals a hard
back breaking eight don't look at that
ten that ten ain't really what it's
talking about
they giving them things out here so you
know you know what it is
it could continue so that's been that's
been pretty much it sir yeah what i'm
just
that's that's about it like uh i wanted
to play uh
a couple of more other games but i'm not
i'm gonna knock that children water out
and then i'm
i'm gonna jump on some other i'm
probably get to turn my playstation on
get the dust off that bad boy
oh wow wow okay hey
don't act like if you don't got two or
three systems one of them got done oh
yeah
i feel like i feel that there's some
truth to that and of course we have the
gaming ninja himself the shinobi
no incognito spreading that realness in
the roman iop not telling you what you
want to hear but what you need
to hear so for me it's been a little bit
actually got a lot of gaming and i was
actually happy with myself today
i got a lot going on i got that animal
crossing
oh man that game man i didn't know what
to expect i didn't know what i was
getting into
that was you that was running from that
dude oh why are you
running why are you you had me
dead you had me
yo i laughed so hard you know
he looked like he was terrified another
i need to throw a fraud alert up and the
reason i need to throw a fraud alert up
king tell me how many people on twitter
tell me how many people in this industry
xbox or playstation came out with
something like animal crossing
they would be relentless
i'm not true no no you know you're onto
something addict
we make a special allowance for nintendo
oh
he's doing so well he's doing so well
you know the dude with the handicap or
something he's doing so well
but if microsoft pull this crap y'all
will condemn us to the end of the earth
if oh this crap y'all will condemn them
to the end of the earth
so that same energy is not felt all the
way around the board savage
i'm just telling you it's always
oh it's nintendo
[Laughter]
listen to it i i will say this for a
person who does it
please
[Music]
what i want to point out and that's why
the fraud alerts up man we have that we
have to be real
here people wouldn't even load this game
up on playstation or xbox
it wouldn't even get past the title
screen they know that's right look at
that
yo i need the pocket watcher to chat
well put the pocket watch it for both of
y'all put it up
listen i know it's going to sell
gangbusters
because the level of a heli bop kool-aid
the jaw dudes
[Music]
i think they send you a free kool-aid
every month
yo shout out to pg say they didn't see
the show the sub box you had to search
for it youtube
yeah they bugging it on twitter
yeah put the judd up on twitter man but
yeah man like a shout out to pixel
bit my man that game's off the chain
don't hate yo it is fun it is hilarious
i will say this in this time
we living in with this whole everything
that's going on like it is really
fun relaxing so i'm early got my island
going on time looking in here making
deals right now we're moving okay
okay let let's let's let's talk about
this king
oh how how long is it before he drops
this game and we never you know
come on tomorrow i don't even think
he'll get to the end of the show to be
honest with you okay
nobody he's frauding right now he just
played the game just so he could say he
did it he's
not gonna do anything he's not gonna do
the wallpaper he's not gonna do the
flooring
he's not gonna go fishing this is too
mundane
for cognito something
are you saying that he he can't chase
people on a beach and be fine
no he's not going to do that why are you
running why are you running
yo so i've been doing that yo shout out
to my boy adam even though he's
slandering me right now
um yo we fired up that state of decay
juggernaut edition my boy attic in these
streets yo
yo so we just messed around with the new
update graphical improvements looking
good
still got some issues though still still
a lot of [ __ ]
still uh checking certain things but um
the new stuff is really fun
yo anytime you need your plague hearts
get cleared yo holla at attic man he go
in there
with that that [ __ ] joy here in
there clearing stuff
he just told me he's like yo sit in the
car i got this i'm like all right
i really did right i i pulled up to the
gas station across the street
i got in between one of the guests i was
like i've always wanted to save this car
he's like what stay in the car
bro he got that that that what is that
grenadine lord something yeah
yeah i have a grenade launcher and
what's funny is like i kept running i
kept running out of ammo and i'd have to
reload
and you can hard drive no i don't
know he can't drive shot salute to the
pc dudes that can't drive that's that's
definitely him
you don't know the story about cog and
driving
in in that game no that's that's that's
petey that ain't me
that was pete i told you this pc gamers
don't know how to drive in state of
decay so i got to take the road in that
situation because they get
attic i have you off the cliff
[Laughter]
i had so much fun man yo shout out to
adago salute to you because he got me
that base i've always wanted i got a big
warehouse we got workshop
i got i got the little farm building the
food spent
two hours getting there you hear that
song it sounds like
friends playing together pause
you know we definitely don't want to go
too much in to say the decay but like
it just it disappoints me at the same
time because it's like
this game has so much potential and i
hope whatever they're doing
undead you know i hope they really yeah
take the you know the past mistakes they
made for the second one and took it like
because
i'm playing this and we're having a
blast like we really are having so much
fun
and the thing is like i said your shot
let me get the super chat real quick
shout out to stitch
666 now find out some chat cog farmville
is also addicting but nobody playing
that
bushes stop that don't be don't be
pocket watching my fun man
yo shout out to slow-mo he said a whole
lot of drink hey all you need to have
listen it is so much fun the problem is
i cannot wait cause i remember shout out
to uh rick
yeah they updated they updated the
juggernaut edition has a lot of update
graphical fidelity
hdr is a little crazy out to man he's
talking about your your little
uh your little decoration
come holly at me with the mp3 i'm not
gonna bother you
the sad part about it we were sitting
there like we was in a garage
taking care of a plague heart and he's
like yo like
did this game really get a huge update
in graphics like it did it just looked
like a 360 game when it first came out
yeah i'm gonna check it today they need
the better service we got four players
man we got two people on deck if you
need people in here
facts i want to shout out to judge
gordon right quick he has a great
article on it
you know talking about the improvements
but also again again when we had richard
foggy on from undead labs
you know at that time they were still
working
towards being with microsoft it was
still microsoft they weren't about
officially a microsoft studio at that
time
right so they're still not the resource
but they didn't have the dedicated
servers because they still had the
tether thing with the limitation
you could tell that game is a lot cpu
and memory bound so i can't wait i would
hope
at least to get a xbox series x patch
for it
you know what i'm saying when it comes
out until the new one comes because the
game got potential man
it is so much fun smitty said super chat
so are we behind
on them did we get this i got the smitty
smith the ps fanboys sir my back hurts
jim ryan why
yeah we got that guy we got stitch yeah
we gotta get pixel bit though get picked
so let's get pixel bit let me find it
man no there was two of them okay okay
there we go
you got a five dollar super chat from uh
pixel pit yo i'm deep
on playstation 5. yeah that you know
it's what's funny is it
that was my playstation your
i think so if you need an og zombie
hunter
also don't hate my on my cross
crossing king that's right don't be
hating nobody that's right
brother trust me i know what it's going
to do y'all already beat me into
submission i'm just wondering what type
of cool are y'all drinking
shout out the lord boo baby chat double
barrel gaming salute we're going to get
into that but other than that
in destiny last thing i will say uh
destiny
on steam meaning you have to have a talk
because i'm very frustrated
ever since this week it's been nothing
but beavers and antiopes and
all these animals and beetles and i'll
be getting booted out
and i can't play trials on pc i can't do
anything on that's the on pc steve
i don't know what y'all did i don't know
what the update happened to the netcode
but it's awful y'all
forced me to go back to xbox and i got
proof because dizzy was in the chat he
saw me
shout out to my man do you always
playing trousers getting some stuff in
but i don't know what's going on man we
got to get that straightened out because
it's really frustrating
and um i'm just getting on your pc sir
i'm about to go in on master race we got
i got that problem
i got a problem with xbox game pass on
pc every time
i try to download it it gets interrupted
and then i got to keep pressing i'm
having a lot y'all making me i told
y'all y'all don't notice with to the
series x and the ps5 i told y'all
so i'm just saying i don't know what's
going on brother come back home no doubt
don't get done
come on no no you already know but
that's all i got so now that we've
gotten into what the lords have been
playing
i want to start with lord willie hood
his video game system history
his journey as a content creator and of
course what led him to becoming the
leader
of the fork nation and creating gaming
beyond the box so
let's start from the very beginning
we'll be what was some of the first
video game systems you had what got you
they gave it
oh god uh let's go whoo
man this could take a while
[Laughter]
uh i think uh honestly the first
gaming system i ever had was the home
pong edition
if you guys remember that
and then i think my neighbor had a
coleco
and yeah and then you know it moved
forward
later in the 70s we had the atari 2600
came out
and you know it was all about the atari
back then and every game pretty much
looked the same almost
but we still bought them um except for
frogger i think it was unique and packed
man
let's go and then
oh my god moving it up i think the next
one
was that i had was in television i can't
remember the name
i think it was just the in television
just in television
i loved that controller that had all
those buttons
i don't feel so bad now you guys are
just as old as me okay i'm better oh no
okay good okay but uh
and then you know back in 80 was 83 84
the crash just just just to clarify i
know nothing about anything they're
saying
that's right you listening are you
talking about you're talking about when
it was a session
when atari decided in the infinite
wisdom to produce
uh what was the e.t in 18 weeks
and make half a million of those
cartridges
don't forget major nelson went to go
find yeah yeah he did
and you know i brought e.t did you buy
e.t
of course i did not okay i brought ep
it's a board an et where you fall in
this pit
you can never get out of that pit and i
did not know that
like as a child i was so distraught
because e.t got stuck in the pit and
every time i played the game
he fell in the pit that was the bug in
the game that i read in the book
and that was the bug that crashed
everything no
yes i don't know which one was worse
that or remember the friday the 13th
game
oh my god oh that was so terrible they
had a fight for which system which only
would happen
yes i remember the nes one no atari
atari had one
yes wow eddie estwick just getting a
life out of me but continue
and that that continued that that
started the whole raging gamer was the
friday the 13th game on atari
and luckily you couldn't throw the
controllers far because they were wired
with the white controller yeah there
were chords on those
and you know back in 83 and 84 when you
know gaming
pretty much went away it all became
arcade machines yes
my family we we owned a restaurant and
we were bringing in
arcade units and
the first one i ever played was space
invaders let's go
with the little things that you had to
shoot oh
which was basically a more advanced
space in there mm-hmm
and then you you got don't forget the
pac-man fever
of everybody nuts that's the og that's
arguably one of the goats
pac-man took it to the next level too
yeah but man pac-man was so
overly you know it was just
it was everywhere you couldn't get away
from it it was on television it was on
cereal
i mean the song was always on the radius
let's go you know then um the more
it was funny because i used to love
working at night man so everybody could
leave and i'd stay in there you'd pull
me up a stool
put arcade machines open up a little
door i'd sit there and play all night
salute to the arcade era we're using
those dimly lit rooms
with just the lights of the skeeds
to be able to socially smoke in front of
people and choke them and kill them
[Laughter]
like when they had no they smoking a
cigarette in your face
you playing street fighter yeah matter
of fact most of the street fighter games
that had the cigarette burns where
people would set the cigarettes down
on the console absolutely
but after that i mean i think it was
what year was it
the uh the original nintendo was 86.87
the snes let's go now you're playing
with power
yeah well you were back then
[Laughter]
you know and their ssd wasn't as good as
but i think it was pretty much mario for
everybody at that time you had mario and
i had the uh
remember the game that came with it you
had that big giant pad that would lay on
your floor
wait you went back and field what was it
called song what was that the power what
was that
power pad power pack you had to jump for
that
right they they was ahead of connect the
connect wasn't right and nobody that
came to your house to play this [ __ ] was
actually standing on their feet and
running you were all sitting on your
knees smacking with your hands
yeah and then you had duck hunt
and then metroid metroid was my first
game you know that i really just
played from one end to the other um and
then
zelda of course and metal gear
mm-hmm and don't forget the original
final fantasy game was also
g and it was a top down thank you it
would definitely be
the original final thing when zelda came
out that was a game changer for me i'm
not really sure
what it was about zelda just struck
first off
i definitely beat the original final
fantasy thank you you don't need to put
that
on me you don't know about that use a
fraud you don't know about that
have you beat the original final fantasy
card
yes i have okay you got it
[Laughter]
continue and you know zelda man i just
buried a lot of my life into zelda we
had i'd have friends come over you know
we'd go to their house we just sit and
play zelda all night
you know we had to find every little
hidden thing about the game yes
and i think the next one i actually got
after that was the um
was the links oh yo you talked to my
heart now
no one ever brings up licks that was
what i'm afraid of
california james oh slime world they had
one of the first times that we all sat
in the dark with handhelds
linked up together and playing what was
that
alien game where we can go from room to
room
that's it yes bro they had yo that joint
had
games right like as far as the graphical
fidelity they was the superior handheld
you know say like it was not even
because they had the eight player attack
with the legend
gameboy but they had that
real juice first revised one i had to
revive
i love links continue
yeah i had to do a lot of work to buy
that one you know i was still a kid then
and i think after that i actually bought
the genesis
and i think oh god i don't remember what
year mortal kombat first came out
it was 90 90 something
i don't know i would say 90s probably
begin in the 90s i would say
um but anyway so that was the one with
the blood oh yeah
remember playing that for the first time
you know you had all these groups
complaining about it
mm-hmm oh my god it's gonna you know
it's gonna cause children to be violent
because what you got younger people in
the chat don't realize you know
everything you guys hear being blamed on
video games we heard it far worse back
but yeah
facts and facts everything caused kids
to be violent it
you know it didn't matter what it was
they even tried to blame ozzy osbourne
for stuff and everybody's
right there biting their heads off
and i still don't remember a lot of
people running around biting heads off
bats
wasn't he the first one with the the
carnivorous oh
there we go
[Laughter]
so you had that genesis you had that
little combat
then sadly in 1990 i joined the army
so i didn't get to do a lot of gaming
you know in the beginning because back
then when you joined the military
there was no internet yeah it really
didn't matter if you took your console
with you or not because chances of you
carrying a tv around were pretty slim
right so but you know during that period
yeah so coming back i think the uh the
next one i bought was a playstation 2
and a drink
i had to make up for all the gaming i'd
lost man because
especially after coming back home it was
i don't know gaming was always a way to
escape
absolutely and that's why i get so
irritated
you know you see people argue on twitter
all day gaming is supposed to be
fun you're supposed to enjoy it and like
king said earlier
playing with friends it's not it's not
all this [ __ ] you see on
excuse me yeah it's not all that stuff
that you see on twitter every day or on
you know youtube channels that's what it
is it's a way to escape
yes and people
i played crap out of my playstation 2
gauntlet remember the uh the game tricky
trick oh ss
yes yeah yep played all those
and one afternoon i went to eb games
because it was eb then mm-hmm yes
remember you had that big giant thing
you plugged into your playstation 2 so
you probably get extra controllers
oh you made a tap
[Music]
went to go pick one of those up and i
saw this big
giant box it was blue and it said the
xbox
by microsoft whoa and i was like hmm
and i was talking this little dude you
know what game that well at eb games i'm
like so what is this thing
and he was saying oh this is this new
box you know by microsoft and blah blah
blah
i was like are there any games available
mm-hmm
and after a couple of minutes i walked
out with this giant 50-pound
box you know looked like huge
oh yeah they were gigantic especially
the originals
and man that was jesus that was all it
took
so they took that hard drive in the
system what did you want
to do halo nothing else
of course a halo but i i had halo and
what was the
oh god what was the other game
i could remember it had it was a ghost
type game the the
you took photos of the ghost oh fatal
frame was it favorites
fatal frame hold on one second i got to
get these super chats that we missed um
smitty smith files from chat with all
those animals on destiny on pc
that's their version of animal crossing
man you pay shout out to brat with the 5
super chat he goes to the lords in new
york be safe
stay away from the wuhan pc4 master race
for life wilmings pc is self-aware big
shout out to wilmington
then we got squirrely dead that's my
brother from yellowknife
canada five dollar super chat can i just
say to will me stop pulling my
gaming history out of my head brother so
you guys are sharing a lot of story so
you got that big
xbox you got those games you did the
research
so were you enjoying the og xbox the big
duke controller
oh yeah i didn't like the controller
that much
because well i'll tell you i've got this
condition it's called
trigger thumb the trigger finger it was
from being in the military
yeah my tendons are a little you know
thicker than normal so
that big giant controller man was kind
of hard
and you know i was so happy to see the
360.
the smaller controllers yes but i mean i
played
i don't remember how many games on the
ogx box i kept it forever
mm-hmm did you do custom soundtracks did
you did you change any music did you add
save music to the hard drive
i didn't get into doing all that oh okay
okay that was cool i know
a lot of people didn't know about it it
was but i just never really got into
doing it
um then i got into 360 and of course you
know play
playstation 2 and all those the 360 i
actually got lucky and got into the beta
test
when live wow and
man that was just the end of it at that
point i was saved baby
yeah i mean i've been i've been on xbox
live i think 17
16 17 years ago hold on let me try to
pull up my stats make sure you ain't
passing me let me see
i got that no i gotta look at your your
uh xbox live profile see what your
number is
uh that's gonna show me that's gonna
show where you act with it that's
that's what's up sometimes
you can be uh messed up by microsoft
shout out to microsoft for messing up my
stuff
uh yeah but i was good from day one but
that won't say that on my joint because
microsoft messed up my stuff
but you know let's keep it rolling
no i actually kind of have to agree with
king too because my first account was
sort of lost because my original
gamertag stricken
and it just it got wiped i have no idea
whatever happened to it it just went
away
oh damn okay yeah so we got a little
more extra years
on on that yeah he sounds like he was
there from day one
and it should be reflected we should
have that redacted microphone
that should definitely come back in that
assault on these accounts
he touched a nerve right there i do
believe so i'm gonna look down
you know these tremendously still stuck
with the xbox whatever now um
just wanna get now did you mess with ps3
at all did you kind of get it
yes i didn't i didn't hear any nintendo
systems past
super edius idiots don't get me wrong i
had the nintendo
because i had kids my son had the
the gamecube and all those and plus
i've got three kids and they're all
grown now uh but
all three of my kids grew up gaming
mm-hmm dad was a gamer
they were gamers that's that's good
simple fact i've got a lot of friends
you know that
their kids didn't game and they'd call
them go hey do you know where bobby is
you know i knew where my kids were you
know when they were home playing games
i knew where all three of them were
facts yeah
i mean go ahead tomorrow so you know my
girls they all had their little ds's you
know my friend had a gamecube in the ds
and plus they had jesus christ my son's
worse than me
but you know my son's actually in the
industry oh wow
salute he wow you know so a lot of
nintendo stuff he
he had so we'd always play on his
but man it's just been
after you know i got on the 360 and on
playstation 3. on playstation 3 i played
mag religiously
if you remember mac yes massive
massive axe game and you know mag was
amazing for what it was even though you
always had that one guy that tried to
take charge of
what all 100 other players yeah
dude dude was 12 years old and had never
been off his couch but he was trying to
tell everybody you know
yeah that's that's addictive two of you
in the bushes and then i mean
uh yeah i need the other three y'all to
make sure you're getting caught you
weren't gonna leave the whole situation
yeah and nobody would ever listen to him
so you guys can start screaming and
yelling into the mic
but um the funny thing
a funny thing actually happened to me
though on the 360. um
there's this little game came out called
gears of war oh
little and
it sounds i mean i was always really
good at the shooters and i'm here to
tell you man that whole [ __ ] you
know you hear people go
monday sundays oh sorry
you hear people say say well you know i
can shoot on call of duty i'd be great
in the military that doesn't it's not
really how that works
just because you can shoot people in
call of duty doesn't mean you can you
know do it
in a real life setting or vice versa
the only difference is if you're in the
military maybe your hand-eye
coordination is a little bit better
yes but i started playing gears of war
and oh my god i was terrible at it
and i do mean i was terrible and i kept
playing kept playing and got better at
it
and i eventually wound up playing
professionally wow
i got to meet cliffy clifford
[Music]
everybody gives cliffy a hard time but
the dude's really not what you see on
social media i promise
he uh he lives he actually has a beach
house like six miles from my house right
now and you know epic is in raleigh
which is only 60 miles away so
it was actually sort of funny because i
was the oldest dude playing in the gears
of war tournament
and this is this guy comes
in you know he's he was i don't know how
to describe him he was like this little
skater type guy he you know he was he
got mad because when the last match when
i won
i pissed it whipped him into submission
damn will because there's something
he gets mad he storms out of the
building and almost breaks the door
but um yeah man i mean that was just a
game changer for me because after that i
started playing more and more
and now when i get free time now that my
kids are grown
mm-hmm you know don't live at home
anymore i get a little more free time so
i dive into a lot of this stuff man
and i won't even talk about the pc stuff
yes
we got everything you have everything
sir i know between between
me and my son i have like 800 games on
steam jesus
and jesus i've got 500
on my xbox like 350 on my playstation
pro
um um so yeah i play a little bit of
everything but um
pc i mainly use it for games i just
can't play on
one of my consoles right because you
know
i'm into the survival horror type games
and stuff like that and there's
there's a few on console but i prefer
them on the pc
oh i've got vr i've got three of them
everything this is a real
fidelity and gameplay level of control
they give you with the new controllers
or
uh what are you looking at like the
oculus like uh sovereign do you have
that or
i've got i've got the oculus s
and i use it the most important there's
two wires that plug into my origin pc
and i've got the quest as well which is
wireless
yeah oh wow i like the s because it is
using my pc
for the power and the the cord that
comes with this thing is like 12 feet
long
so it's not really an issue you don't
have to have little cameras and
does it have a screen door no okay so oh
yeah because all right let me explain
what the screen door is that's so
it's a camera on the outside so he
doesn't bump into stuff
oh yeah he made the pass through yeah
yeah he does have that
okay yeah so that's that i think that's
very important i thought that was a huge
innovation
when it came to vr so you don't you know
knock over the stuff that you have in
your house and stuff
yeah yeah
if you got this thing hooked up to your
pc and you paid a lot for your pc the
last thing you want to do is trample
your pc
xbox services maxed up my joint as well
hate that as far as i guess his account
and all that so yeah yeah man i hear you
but listen you had a lot
of gaming man like pretty much
everything so clearly i i would
assume lord will be the console what
stuff you you get
quite a lot it's very humorous to you
that's because for you you're like bro i
got i got everything buddy
i'm gonna sound like king on this
statement why am i gonna worry about
something that doesn't make me money you
know i don't
i don't work for microsoft or
playstation
do i favor my xbox yes
fair enough do i still play all the
playstation titles and do i
i have six xbox x's i have four
playstation pros in my house
um my wife's a gamer too awesome
if you guys remember back in the 360
days the gamer chicks that used to be on
on the 360. my wife was one of those
oh wow original gamer checks wow um
so i play i mean do i favor my xbox i
know
that's a thing on twitter lately well
everybody's got a
got a favorite favorite of course i mean
i don't know what the issue is
i have a lot of favorites and different
things but yes i do prefer my xbox
because why it stinks with my pc
because
a lot of people resisted games coming to
pc with me so i'm glad that you said
that there's a lot
yeah we need to hear that yeah i mean
the thing is no i don't always want to
play on my pc
thank you and don't get me wrong i've
seen this a lot on twitter too
oh it's going to destroy your pc i'm
here to tell you that xbox don't get
wrong i'm buying it today it comes out
it is not going to touch my origin
i feel i think it's not even going to go
close but now it does
it does kind of trample on the alienware
yeah
what are you talking about in that
origin let's just talk specs
one of him if i if i got into
i mean i had this thing built we have
multiple 2080ti's
is that what we're saying well we don't
i've got we've done well we're pocket
watching
how much you spent i will send you all
the specifications oh oh okay
so we'll me you know you know when you
go into the like the the
the the customization menu that there's
extra stuff that you can't even put in
the menu that's what we'll meet
we'll get out here my like i said
earlier my son works in the industry so
he
he sit down with me and he's like okay
dad this is everything you want in this
pc if you want to keep it current and
you want this
and i'm like sweet and by the time he
got up to the price
i was like that's more than i paid for
your car
and he's like but you want it right i'm
like sure
so put up the millions millions adding
for wilmie's pc and his son for building
out the most powerful
two generations ahead pc out in the game
i mean this thing is it's guaranteed not
to get corona
or anthrax you know
and like somebody said in chatter it's
self-aware it actually speaks to me at
times you got skydeck in the crib
in my house i promise oh my god yo
salute
they got the millions of the chat is
really lit yo love what the game is
today
so i gotta move on real quick man i
gotta ask about you know what i'm saying
just your journey as a content creator
cause obviously you told us the story
which is truly humbling like that you
heard us when we were one of the first
podcasts you hit her
so then like you channel that and
transition from that
like how did you now say you know what i
want to kind of start a youtube chat i
want to
do the [ __ ] nation gaming behind the box
like how did that whole process start
it's actually kind of funny it all falls
back you know
to uh that gaming group on facebook
uh because you know every well everybody
here on the podcast knows you know when
we were younger man gamers
you were bottom tier i mean oh it wasn't
cool it wasn't cool
it wasn't cool at all like i've said
before you know we were just one step
above you know the guys who played
dungeons and dragons in the library
and
[Music]
doing the uh the facebook group you know
a lot of us were sitting there talking
a lot of the admins were like you know
it'd be great to do a podcast
and i was like yeah but you know with
the state of
did you ever watch the show the guild i
have never
watched it the guild uh i gotta
think of her name right now um i love
watching that show they used to play it
you can get it for free on the xbox 360.
and it was so funny because
everything that they went through as
gamers
you could actually see it in the
community and
if if nobody really knew that was one of
the reasons they canceled the show
because the gaming community just became
so toxic
yeah that was one of the reasons they
stopped doing it
so we had decided
that we were going to do a podcast
i had no clue how to do it
i knew you needed youtube yes
i had that part down okay um
but the funny thing was i had no idea
how to set it up so i'm i'm sitting here
i'm researching everything
i'm like okay i need this this and this
download that download this this
and i wanted to do something different
because i'd use youtube for my business
um when youtube first started coming
around and you were actually hanging on
mobile phones
it helped me grow my business right
because i was making youtube videos for
my company
oh that's what's up they were getting a
lot of hits and
it actually increased my business quite
a bit
and then you know a few years ago when
they decided to copyright everything
it kind of went downhill but um
so i was like you know we can do this
because gaming
is like i said it's always been
something special to me it's always been
a way to get away in a way to have life
absolutely it's life i've got friends
that
i've been playing with for 17 years i
still haven't to meet face-to-face
wow yeah
but i decided to put it all together and
i had left this xbox group because
i got really tired you know it was it
was all supposed to be just about xbox
and i'm sitting back going
come on dude let's talk about something
else it's not just always about xbox
right so a lot of us left the group we
started a different group
and i called it gaming beyond the box on
facebook
okay let's go so we decided to do the
podcast
and i decided to set it all up
and i did it with my admins at first
man that was terrific
little rough start little little little
shake i mean
it was just it was terrible i knew what
i wanted to do
i knew how i wanted to do it i knew what
i wanted the show to be like
these guys just weren't getting that
vibe got you
they wanted to complain about dlc and
i'm like that's great dude
you know everybody's over the dlc you
know argument like two years ago
mm-hmm um and just it was actually
pretty bad i mean i had guys that want
to show up to do the podcast
oh wow um well this is supposed to oh
yeah and they all won't do it you know
until i put all this time and effort
into it and got it all set up and one of
the first people
actually i contacted was our good friend
jake um
i think god's graphic you know i need
tell me how to make you know this this
layout you know for
channeling all this and that and jay's
like no problem man i got you know
good tool come to me you know we'll talk
about what we want
you know what you want all this so
as luck would have it i met a guy on
twitter named evil ghost
evil ghost and so
he and i were talking one afternoon and
found out he's in myrtle beach
okay which isn't but 60 45 60 miles from
me local and see let's go
and uh so he and i started talking about
you know maybe you should come on my
podcast one afternoon
okay and so he did he's like well you
know i've got a couple other people
want to come on too if you're interested
sure because the guys i had on here
first really wasn't uh
wait yeah it went popping oh they
weren't they wouldn't even talk dude
i don't know and i'm like in the podcast
you just sit there all day you know
we're just gonna listen to you open
soda cans you know nobody wants to hear
that
and so that's what i hooked up with fort
boy
bomber that's what we all got together
and
you know i we sit down you know we
discussed how we wanted to do it what we
wanted the show to be
like and all that stuff and then we just
started kind of
putting it together it's still a work i
mean it's it's always
you know it's always a work in progress
brother oh yeah
always and but we didn't want i kind of
modeled my show
after one of you guys oh a little bit
a little bit of rdx yes
boys
actually helped me out with some things
too you know we we talk quite a bit
that's what's up and that's kind of how
i modeled our show except i wanted ours
to be not as serious
like you guys on that end okay okay so
you want that you want to have balance
that you have the fun
but also you know what i'm saying a
little the attacking the little aspects
of that as well
oh yeah i mean you you want to talk
about the the consoles and the games but
i mean you really want to entertain
people
absolutely i mean i look at it this way
you can you can hear the same news from
just about anybody
you have to make it entertaining to keep
them coming back
that's the fact you know like nobody
keeps
if you just gonna sit and straight read
off a paper or on these sites
what's the point mm-hmm you know they
can just go
over to digital foundry and read
themselves mm-hmm shout out to graphic
guy he said like retro renegades too
high will be
[ __ ] shot the graphic guy got the
heart up smiling that's what's up man
and you know we just wanted to make it
fun and we just want to make it
you know funny to the people coming in
and which it is
we we do we do a lot of giveaways uh
which you do i think i gave away six
copies of doom eternal
wow uh last year alone there was 47
xboxes 32 playstation
whoa um let's see and they're
and some certain youtubers said i was
doing it to make friends
no
[Laughter]
you ain't had no friends by buy the
that's the verdict
friends go to the bar and buy the bar
out you gotta find
it there are better ways of making
friends you know what i'm saying
friends because the hearts of chris can
you have an xbox
yo he said what are these giveaways
going on yo people in the chest say they
they need to know where
they they want to know when gaming
beyond the box giveaways
the funny thing is you know we uh i did
it before the podcast was even a thing
wow you know i've been i've been you
know watching the gaming community for
years on twitter
but you know i i would see people you
know online saying oh man you know my
xbox broke my playstation pro i can't
afford to get a new one
i would message them and say look you
know this is not trying to be weird if
you want to send me your paypal link
i'll shoot you the money
no strings salute i got i got a slow
i got to slow you down one second with
me because i'm not going to gloss over
that
at the end of the day like again you
know
coming across your content coming
obviously we have a lot of mutual
friends so that's how we were able to
to wake up and stuff but you know i do
want to say
from from what i've seen you're one of
the few just
generally charitable members of the
community you've done so much for so
many i
i hear will be hood stories about like
almost like that dude you're out by ty
you blew out the side of the road
you don't say like you're that guy in
the community and i really don't want to
not you know understate that because you
know it's really special thing that you
do and again like i said i hear the
stories of i just want to
knock gloss over that and also ask you
like what inspires you to be like look
you know i want to help my fellow gamers
in need i mean we just came off that
amazing charity streamer
stream for dizzy you know and everything
i mean you were one of the first people
to reach out to me and say hey [ __ ] what
are we doing for dizzy
you know for a situation with cancer and
things like that so just tell me like
what inspires you to really spearhead
these charitable movements for your
gaming community
oh man you're gonna make me dig deep
let's go bro let's this will be here
we're in the room
let's do it ah well
you know i did i was able you know to
afford these consoles and stuff as a kid
even though i was an orphan
i mean for the better part you might as
well say i mean
my dad was a vietnam vet he was he was a
drunk he was into drugs
he was just a terrible parent
and i pretty much took care of myself
wow
i did you know i wish i would have had
anything to eat have you ever ate bread
and worcestershire sauce
you know but um you know
and i knew deep down he didn't mean to
be the way he was but he just really
couldn't help it at least that's what i
told myself it made me feel bad
life perked up when i moved in with his
sister which is my aunt and her husband
it picked up some right but they still
weren't the nicest of people
but um i mean i got to know what i went
through as a kid
you know and the things i wanted i mean
man i would you know there was no
gofundme back in the 80s
fact you went down the street with a
lawnmower you know in a little
wheelbarrow you
just cut people's grass or did whatever
to make money buy whatever you wanted
um so i've been in a lot of spots where
some of these people have been
i feel when i started my business years
ago
you know i sit and watched you know man
we didn't have anything as you know we
were putting out everything for our
company to make sure our company
survived
because i had a dream and i had to do
what it took to make it happen
and and so we did a lot of times you
know we went without
but i'm in a better spot because
everything i've worked for
is came through because i just never
stopped myself made self pay let's talk
about
seven seven days a week 28 hours a day
you know but um and now that my kids are
grown
they don't live at home they're i've
already got them through college all
that good stuff
oh you know everybody my home's paid for
everything's paid for
i look at people man and i put myself in
their position
i see a lot of people you know on on
social media the same
like we were so i just try to help
people out
bro and some people do try to take
advantage
uh i have had people uh
yeah you know excuse me when i when i
was joking around earlier you know about
the boob implants
yeah you know that actually came to me
in a dm stop
stop playing we got gamers out here
trying to
oh you know i mean not for nothing his
wife could have been very very
back-chested
you know listen man he could have had
that tear in his
eye like please kind sir
[Music]
yeah the guy was basically like you know
well you know me and my wife aren't
getting along you know we got two small
children
blah blah blah i think this really
helped our marriage i'm like call dr
phil homie
it makes it visually pleasing
stop encouraging these people to hit up
will be for these fools listen i don't
know i ain't encouraged that
i just told you to just make the
situation look a little bit brighter
oh my god i did i just did not tell you
to call
[Laughter]
that's where you know that's where a lot
of it came from man because i've been
there myself you know
so i've tried i just try to to help
people out
and like it does you know sometimes you
do get some crazy people you know that
come up and
yeah ask you for things like there's one
dude and i'll admit it uh because i've
talked about it before
mm-hmm i just paid a dude's mortgage
he owed me but then uh
about three weeks went by i sent him his
the
mortgage payment and he was like well
i really need to get a car yo
i'm like well dude you really need to
get a job
you know you're having issues
up at this point well um that's crazy
man
that is crazy things people would do
they try to take advantage of it
i'm from i'm from new york so new york
you know and not that's not all new
yorkers but uh most new yorkers are a
little bit more
no you know like uh you know shout out
to bloomberg for making his kids work
for
money that he had billions of you know
um
but i i can see how people can try to
take advantage of the kind heart and i
don't think that you know that stuff is
right but
um you have done a hell of a lot
um i've actually seen it um i've heard
about it
and like like like [ __ ] said you're the
guy on the side of the road you know you
have flat tire hey
don't worry brother there you go you're
good man
i help you um i believe that is
and not that you're doing it for
anything other than self gratification
because inside yourself you feel good
and you're doing it for yourself and the
giving
is what's what makes you happy you're
not looking for nothing in return
it's for yourself and i believe that's
the best part right there
other than you know other people that's
looking for stuff in return
fast bro y'all we got super chat real
quick squirrely there at 82 again
canada to follow super chat damn woman
your story is bringing back childhood
memories
puff wheat and water bro struggle is
real this is back
dizzy daddy has hats off the wobbly hood
thank you for everything bro there's so
many people
man like i said you your influence who
you've touched
in this short period of time of me
actually interacting with what i've seen
has truly been a rock one and again i
don't wanna like i said understate
all the things you did man it is amazing
and i love how you tied it into the fact
that
from where you came from you're
empathetic you understand what it is to
come from nothing
build yourself up and a lot because
that's the thing a lot of people who are
in your position or well off once they
get there
they forget what that struggle was i
mean they're cool they don't look bad
and the cool thing that you do and again
that's why i had to celebrate your hand
in the realm
is is that you're always thinking about
others ahead of yourself
we're just gonna have to get some
protection for you these dudes with the
mortgage though we can't be having that
money
dudes out here we gotta protect
you now comes in handy
[Laughter]
exactly all we got you don't say gotta
keep it easy with that part
but look man tremendously history i
could talk to you for hours bro we got a
lot of just a lot of show left
but i have to ask the questions that we
asked the guests here in the room here
we go
gotta ask these man so i know
the questions that we asked so again all
those systems will me
but i need that top five video games of
franchises of all time
for whitney hood hmm okay
xbox fear i'd really love to see the
fear series come back
i would love to see it and of course
doom i mean
every name i own every doom i would have
say other than that one assassin's creed
odyssey kind of brought me back
into assassin's creed i've probably
dumped 150 hours
into odyssey okay okay
um that's three that's three
two more two more any generation any
could be a friend
condem from sake i remember
then i would probably have to say day's
gone
wow okay first time days god has
made and almost turned christopher hard
world up yeah
he's about to pop up he just get a back
flip his head
that's the first the last time we'll
ever hear that oh my god
break it down right there's going down
yes yes
look at it with the yeses yeah break it
down the thing about days gone you know
it was all about the story
and man i kept playing that game can't
play that game like
does he find her yes or no and you just
had to keep playing it to find
out and then when you find her and i'm
trying to say but i mean come on
everybody i don't know i didn't play i
want to buy the game but i thought they
was going to get it on game pass sorry
oh my god
um you played on pc um but then
when you do find her you're like okay
now what
and the story kept going and i just i
just had to keep playing man i just
i got wrapped up in the world and
everything with the game i know it had
some issues but they didn't match a lot
of them
okay and it just the story really got me
into the game
so the story is where it really
resonated with you like okay
okay that's a first i gotta shout you
out on that man days gone
made a top five salute on that now i
gotta ask a new question shout out to my
boy
lord boosting excel he actually debuted
for us of
want to add this you'll be the first
what is that it's not what you think
about it
out of all the consoles out of all the
system what is your
favorite console of all time oh yeah
it's got to be a console
yes one cop i'd say 360.
so let's why why we had so many games
with 360.
yeah i mean yeah you did have a whole
red ring of death things
[Laughter]
i donated a couple myself um okay but
other than that i mean there's just so
many different games for the xbox 360
man you couldn't go wrong
i mean there were tons and tons of games
for it
online i love the dash remember the
blade i'm going to dash with the blades
yes it was like they had the perfect
thing that's why i was so upset with the
xbox one because it was like
they had the perfect system it was like
it wasn't broke why are you trying to
fix it like
it was you know why they tried to
because i mean well i had to because
they went from one chip set to the next
so
yeah but the dog man i don't know with
the tv
we're gonna get into that we gotta leave
that alone but salute to the 360 being
mentioned
the debut of the favorite console of all
time
wilmington with a tremendous gaming
history we got a lot of show
so we gonna get it moving you know what
i'm saying but um last week's poll
results are in the people have spoken to
the question with the mostly positive
reception of ori and the will of the
west
how do you think microsoft should handle
their continued relationship
with moon studios and the ori franchise
the winner
of a fairly runaway three-way iop poll
at 66 percent
was sign moon studios immediately
lock orient coming in at second place
with
damn just 20 of the vote was maintain
the current relationship
let moon studios decide the fate of
already and in last place at 12 percent
i don't care they just need to fix them
damn bugs in the game
the lords have participated lord
sovereign uh what do you think sir
they should have done it after ori in
the blind forest like
yeah i'm gonna do it man that aura in
the blind forest to me
forget about one of the words i haven't
even touched with a little wisp yet
it's one of the best when it comes to
metroidvanias i love business that's the
reason you missed last week wasn't this
because you
you don't want to talk about what the
wiz you're like hey you need that game
i don't want you i don't want to see
that i want to talk about it yet i'm a
metroidvania head
and what they managed to do with the
first one kind of
besides the look of the game you played
gameplay a bit
how difficult it was that came out of
left field people were like
backfired by how challenging the game
was um
it's kind of perfect there's some
difficult parts of it that are a little
unfair
but to me honestly they need to design
them after that
so for me yeah if you're looking for
a studio that can really really be up
there with the with the nintendo's when
it comes to like a mario type game
with it i would love to see what they
could do with something in in the 3d
space
they need to sign them right now fair
enough man
it's interesting to see i wonder if moon
wants that relationship how it is or
whatever but
great that's yeah it could be moon
that's what i'm thinking
but look man we got a lot of times we
got a lot of [ __ ]
before we move on to the actual topic
play
the res evil demo i did yes i did
what did y'all think i liked it i loved
it to be honest with you i liked it but
like i felt like a lot of that
that oh my god was left with the second
one
what's left in the second one it's like
but it doesn't take away from how good
it is it's just like
it's fun but like that surprise factor
is over
right yeah i felt the same like the oh
my god factor
is beautiful and i the fact that you're
taking res evo 3 which was a
it was fine and it was different but it
wasn't you know
not a lot of people played it that
people kind of tied up the regular
formula at that time so the fact that
bringing it to
an audience that wants more of that is
fantastic but
that wow factor of like wow look what
they did with this game
yeah it's not there anymore it looks
better than one um too though
yeah mm-hmm yeah man again salute salute
again
you did pick it up right you did you
enjoyed it oh yeah absolutely you're the
lord of horror so i had to ask you the
lord oh man
all about it i'll probably i'll probably
wait for a cell in that game to be
honest with you
oh yeah i did that i did that on rather
than evil too so
uh i can feel you out of you you know
what's crazy many games like
you know with everything going on in the
world like we playing games like rez
evil
um state of the game
yo shout out towards the boy shout out
i want to shout out to my boy daniel may
god norris car no the division
right state of decay only state he has a
great article up right now on lords of
gaming.net i got to plug my boy
and he was like why i believe the title
summons the effect of why depressing
games are important right now
and it's amazing please check it out
it's on that front page lords of
gaming.net
tremendous article of how to deal how to
cope and stuff like that but
we got a lot of show going on so we
going to get it popping lord king is
going to
set it off first as soon as this news
was revealed about the xbox series
x he hit us up in the dm they said that
is my topic
boot on the neck type talk so we're
going to get to it man okay a lot of
stuff you want me to frame and you all
want me
to go yeah man so look a lot of stuff
that went down this week but obviously
you know surprise bombshells from
microsoft
xbox series x full text spec revealed
numbers performance and not only that
not only did we get the the full stat
sheet behind
the hood people taking it apart he uh
phil dominance maximus spencer as his
king
probably calls him um he got that box
over to um
what is it austin evans one of the top
tech guys in in youtube
and of course the legends of tech
digital foundry salute to john lennon my
boy
it was good to see you on the screen
he's been here in the realm before we'll
try to have him back
and of course the legend of talking tech
with the with the tremendous posh accent
richard ledbetter he was out there
talking those numbers man so we got a
lot to see behind the hood
so king i'm gonna give it to you a lot
of bonds have dropped this is completely
unexpected all we thought we were
getting
was some gdc stuff this week but again
we got some bombs so let's talk about a
king well um
i told you guys uh how i feel about what
uh
the fulfill movement let's let's just
call it what it is
um because i i said on boom i said you
know one time
something can happen two times is a
coincidence three times is a pattern
uh four times is the trend well fool's
always trending right now
you know and um the things that he's
doing
is uh what you asked for you know a lot
of people a lot of these fake uh sony
fans out here you know
they they tell you stuff like you know i
just want microsoft to do better
i just i just want microsoft you need to
demand more
what we did we demanded more guess who
heard us
the boss the ball hurt us the boss is
actually listening right now he's
probably listening right now
and he's like yeah i heard you i'm
freaking tired of these dudes talking
about power so boom
bust you in the mouth and then y'all
thought it
keep that same energy king you know
because we're coming tomorrow
and you came up short limping to the
point we will get to
so you know when somebody's supremely
confident
in in in their tech and their situation
and then
they ducks is on the road they call
people over yo
you're the best in the field right come
over here and check the stuff i see
now phil did it before but if he does
the same trick again it's not a good
trick right
but what he did with this trick right
here is he let it spread out on the
table and say yo y'all put it together
like little legos he they took
a series x like legos and put it
together in the back
and now now now get this right so
to do the same trick it's not impressive
it's a trick with digital foundry
austin evans though
[Laughter]
see this is where it's a little bit
different just a little slighter hand
comes out
he slid in pause
you thought it was just gonna be digital
founder because you got digital foundry
in pocket they're gonna do whatever he
says
oh but but it's austin though
just get out to for getting there and
and putting his spin on it like only he
can
shout out to the 1.5 million views at
the time
you know uh because people say nobody's
interested in microsoft
um right now
shout out to austin for digging deeper
see now
i i'm definitely pulse i'm definitely
going to tell you
digital foundry did their numbers
digital foundry did they thing
digital foundry had enough content they
did they was able to do three videos
so this was done
weeks before you saw silicon
you saw tech you saw demos
you saw games you saw ray tracing in
real
life games um
you know no no no no magician tricks
this was actual stuff happening in front
of your eyes
so my question to the world is right now
what more does this man have to do
to you make you understand he's dead
serious about this
um hmm shout out to cody remember he
said aust devins don't cap for xbox or
playstation he have master race
so he knows series expo let's get into
it man let me step out for a second
we'll get back to him
i want to get actually to solve this
last week so we get a chance so we saw
first so solve man obviously we got to
break down a lot of tech information
what um impressed you about this about
idiot tech specifically
and about the presentation itself well i
think
the presentation let's go there first
right yeah let's do it
i i have vastly different things to say
about the presentation on the
playstation side and why i think that
that part of the playstation
presentation failed is that they made
consumer facing right absolutely so even
though it was still
based off of what they were going to
talk about at gdc they
realized that they were now they weren't
they didn't say hey we're sending this
particular presentation to devs only and
we're doing
in consumer phases let's save the
playstation talk but you know what what
i'm saying
i'm comparing it to this okay it's just
that
they made it so that the average
consumer
can glean from it what they need to and
not get too much into the weeds with the
numbers and stuff they don't care about
they just numbers and stuff that they
can relate to
right so to me that was it was very
important that they were able to put out
that technical information for people
who wanted it
and then that it kind of dilute it down
to the simplest
aspects of it so that somebody who's
just looking at general power wow this
is just powerful
right right um so i'm glad they did that
in terms of
the details the fact that they confirmed
that 12 right even though
because people talk about how teraflops
it's just a form of measurement and it
is
right but 12 teraflops of gpu power
in rdn in our dna 2 is vastly superior
to what we've had in the past so that in
and of itself is exciting
in a box that we expect to be five to
six hundred dollars
yes right you can still talk about pc
master race and uh absolutely right but
remember a pc
needs to brute force everything every
aspect
every ev every piece of a pc brute
forces
the thing that it's supposed to do
that's what i love about consoles there
and a console is an eloquently built
system that kind of condenses all that
stuff in a way to work with
with one of the in in a way that's all
purpose exactly
so for me that the fact that they were
able to literally like the king said put
it together like legos
and it just seemed like such a
simplistic process
right that they for me they married
simplicity and simplicity
and overall uh development for the
making it easier for development
wow while pushing power in a way that we
haven't seen on the console side before
so that's
that really impressed me about the
entire presentation and finally getting
the specs
mm-hmm mm-hmm quick we got two super
chats we missed i got to ask you a
question right after that
um we got smitty smith find out super
chat playstation fanboy
but but the pro gonna be a beast xbox
forget your pro
we're here to talk about your cards with
the book of fix
[Laughter]
smitty's never again find out it's gonna
be 13
x y stop right there the book of acts
is in his bag right now so look at this
video
i gotta bring it back to yourself though
i wanna ask like
as far as the rollout because again
we didn't know like this was like
another stealth
drop so to speak right so you know we're
just supposed to get
uh was it game stack live right that was
the only thing that was set to go to me
like how do you feel they're handling
rolling out information because just
like maybe two weeks ago we were talking
about
you know obviously e3 you know it's been
canceled the pressure's
on them to to present correctly in an
old digital even king brought out though
i don't know about the freestyle
like how are you liking this he shut my
mouth straight up yeah
he came for you bro you liking the
freestyle ability of double on their
feet disseminating their
information i think it's great i think
you know we've criticized them in the
past for
for these weird sort of presentations
where everybody seems like fake excited
and
um and just to you have to you have to
sort of dilute that down to the message
and if the message is clear and if the
message is impressive
right yeah people are going to listen
and people are not going to care about
all the stuff that's going on
on the side and i think you know in the
world we're living in right now where
it's imperative that they
that all this information is
disseminated digitally is the only way
to do it
um i i think the way they've been
dropping it
has been great as opposed to you know
what places have been doing but
very quiet up until now because you keep
people excited and
you drop little tidbits right you drop
little tidbits you hit little things
that hint that
how many you know how how fast the gpu
is little things like
exactly how fast a cpu is and little
things like that and then and
and then just drop the whole thing and
give people the entire breakdown
right so now we're at the point we have
the specs we have the look of the
machine we have
we have a real idea of how this is going
to function
right like king said we actually have we
don't have we haven't seen any new games
yet but we've seen
what it could do with older games and
tangible presentations
presentations that show you because
again their message
is is different than playstations in
that you're talking about across
generations completely across
generations
so for people who are invested in this
ecosystem and have like will me said and
like i
i i'm the same way i have hundreds of
games
i want to know that this is moving
forward in a way
that that that that is indicative of
what they've been doing so far already
like if you look at
compat on the one what they do with back
compat
is amazing right mm-hmm i'm gonna keep
it i'm gonna keep it a buck right that
that
yes four back compact i don't
it seems to me because he it was gleaned
over right at the bit of thing
is very much you can just play your ps4
games on here
you're not getting much of an upgrade
mm-hmm
i don't know that's too bad in the world
and well it's debatable but he didn't
talk about it no i'm talking about
everything about that whole process is
debatable because
we'll we'll get to it later we'll get to
it yeah so
i think like the things they've done
with back compact
that that's the standard now i don't
want to hear anything less than that
um
to me the way they've been messaging is
great keep doing it the next thing
obviously
is more teasers of games right right
of course of course of course let's
let's see the ui let's see the interface
let's see it actually you know
in a real-time situation with a brand
new game see how
the functions yeah and then you know as
we get closer to
you know the et the et the er three
time frame they maybe still do it in the
same time frame
mm-hmm big game drop no doubt smitty
smith is back y'all five hours of chat
remember when the screen turned black
and people thought they was about to
show a game
and it just said thank you
when i get to that part boy i'm gonna
light it up
[Laughter]
i'm gonna give you the match man we're
gonna both put gasoline on this
the book of ex minnie smith is in his
bag we're trying to be a boss movie
for this bank listen jonathan b better
show up y'all letting somebody
eat out here he's doing it up man you
know what i'm saying but look so triple
i see what you're saying song i hear
that it's will be back i don't know what
we have to step away for a second
will be are you back sir he is still in
the bushes so hopefully we'll get him
back
but let's get at it man so adam i know
you're not the biggest
fan of tech talk we know the realm knows
but
just in general like how did you feel
about you know
microsoft's you know surprising surprise
of all this information
and then um just in general like how did
you feel about what was discussed
you know the funny thing is i didn't
even watch that till like literally
like almost the next day remember that
we just played destiny we sit there
i don't even remember what we was doing
i was waiting in those uh almost no
loading screens on uh pc
gaming but you know i'm sitting here
watching it on the left screen and i'm
playing destiny on the right
and i'm like i'm like cognito
they ain't playing like i'm sitting here
when he
showed the minecraft and what ray
tracing looks on it
i was like i didn't want to play
minecraft in like five years but uh
a lord might do it like come on like
let's get going
is i'm not a big fan of digital foundry
because i feel like they got no taste
uh they they just sit there and they're
just like oh you know
the the with the the tear flops of this
and the terror flops
you know microsoft microsoft didn't just
rely on digital foundry
they rely on another dude some austin
dude what's his name
austin evans was the dude to go to to
know what this thing was going to do
because you know he he gave it that
entertainment he gave
that that you know the i wouldn't even
say it was dry humor it was just you
know a little bit of
extra fun that you could watch so it
wasn't about just the tech
like he said that you know what the
first time watching him
yes that was the very first time
watching okay yeah so so should we
salute can we put out phil dobbins
maximus spencer if i'm making the right
move to get yeah
demographics to learn about tech phil
dominance who did that for you
you know you know what i you know what i
think i think he heard
the um digital foundry talk
before and said okay
we have to corner the market shadow
listen when i when i say phil dominance
maximum expense i'm talking about the
team because he's just not a single
entity that dominates over the team
you know um like he told you before uh
it was a
into was it an intern or a rookie that
brought up the suggestion
for uh the reveal on the awards show
so a good leader his team
yeah i do want to say something you know
a little a little nice thing that
will me said earlier
[Laughter]
update from sony almost all 4 000 games
will work day one 100 i'm gonna blow you
out of the water will be boosted to take
your batteries
i just clarified it for someone
that has always been vivically clear i
do not
care about tech i don't care about tech
almost every time we do a tech
topic i almost pretty much pass
but my question to face is what what
does the boost mean
let me just answer his uh 4 000 thing
because you know i'm not going to have
to have you know falsifying facts
you know they they went up to their blog
and
you know they reprimanded uh you know
mark cerny
basically because mark told the truth
and that one little spill
that he gave you he gave you the truth
we have a hundred titles that we're
looking at
let's let's talk about that when we get
to the playstation yeah
we got a lot we're just gonna get to
this part real real quick okay we have
100 titles that we're looking at
and out of those 100 we're going to put
your favorites
now i don't know where you got 4 000
from but that's the revision
because they didn't like the the what
mark told the truth on
so if we're going to if we're going to
take everything that mark said
in that whole little magic trick
then you're going to take what mark said
for the gospel
so thank you for the 4.99
and putting out the fake facts when mark
told you the truth betty smith is back
on facebook bk hey
finally super chat i just don't want the
smoke i want the whole damn forest fire
[Laughter]
you know what man i feel like we need to
emote with the book of acts at this
point but you know
what i want to state that you know we've
got a little sidetrack there for a
second
is they made it from someone that didn't
care about tech
yes they made it more adaptable to me
like when i watched it they were like
they said okay you know we got this
remember i told you guys i was like i
don't care about the
uh the the ability to go through
multiple games
and go back because i still don't really
care about that but
they made it more appealing they're like
look we can go from state to decay to
forza to
you know to halo and you could do this
pretty easily pretty efficiently
and and i really enjoyed that they gave
you a demonstration on
everything they said they didn't just
say it like you know we can do this and
then we can do that
and uh you know if you look at this
diagram behind me nation
right benchmarks showing right again i'm
glad you're saying what you're saying
because again your generation is who
they need to win over
right your generation is the people who
may not
necessarily care about all that tech
stuff but they they want to know about
it and but for you to say that you
really enjoyed the austin evans thing
really shows how much marketing is kind
of in there
and we let's go and we gotta be real too
like you've been on marketing
yeah my generation is the majority of
the consumers like
facts it's real so to hear you say these
things is really kind of impossible to
get
i'm gonna give it right back to you i
just gotta get my brother gaming forte
find out a super chat change in
leadership can flip the online mind
share of these companies wait i gotta
repeat that say
tell that to your uh podcast leader
because i've been saying this to him
behind the scenes
changing leadership can flip the online
mind share of these companies
ever since phil took over and threw
myerson in the bushes
xbox has been mixed
i agree with the first buffer show i
know king is riding for the second part
but i agree but definitely mine should
continue
and then we'll get uh will mean you know
the only thing i have to say
is they did their beef
a really good job at not just throwing
out
information and just like what i what i
feel like
they used to do is they would just throw
information and like if
it's something you understand that some
of you understand it if some of you
don't some of you don't
but it feels like they're like look we
got this you know we got the gdc
presentation
we can't just say this information what
we got to do
is the week before let's drop some
videos
on youtube with the digital fans with
the austins and
let's present it because these people
actually they speak to dumb people all
the time
so they can easily speak to a crowd that
doesn't necessarily understand tech
i'm not no tech idiot but i do know
enough that i can
follow certain points right but he
you know but i don't know enough to look
at a diagram
so he found out so you know they went to
the people that's like
you guys have built a career off of
talking to people that don't know
anything about this stuff
so we're going to give you the console
and not now i'm just saying
they they literally flew them and gave
them the console they didn't do
some you know some behind the curtain
thing where they can't see what they're
playing
they let them assemble the console
it's not just some some myth that
they're doing
they have the console here is the box
their physical reputation of the
big points man gotta get the super chat
you know the war rages on between phase
twenty three bk and
somebody spin all right so we got file
and super chat for phase 23 bk
[ __ ] needle 100 titles boosted means
enhanced to take advantage of the
playstation 5 for better frames and
resolution
then smitty smith with five dollars with
the clapback do you know what happens to
sheep that just blindly walk around
xbox you get lamb chops tonight
the book of eggs
never confirm launch window we have no
date on their rollout it's looking good
it was going to change their name we'll
get to the playstation stuff over there
ready for that oh my god i'm sorry
so look we heard the super chats will be
low will me has he returned is he back
in the realm
oh i'm here okay my man so okay so there
we go so all right now we got this
information
you know what was your feeling coming in
this week surprise
info tech info blast from xbox what did
you feel about the news and what
did anything excite you specifically oh
the whole thing excited me of course
because i'm a gamer
but um they're not letting up
and it's either you dominate the market
or you become second and i think you're
going to see this pretty much
the whole generation will i mean i feel
like they got a they got like a little
booklet a little little tablet and
they're just sitting there looking at
that and they got like
diagrams how you would see in those in
those uh
choice games where it's like you make
this choice we're doing this you make
this choice for doing this
and he's literally got like everything
they do they're like
if they do this we're doing this they do
this we're doing this
i'll definitely say this like you know
phil is always gonna be the one to
downplay the
you know who's better than what the
council or stuff but
it's obvious that narrative bothered
phil
it's obvious that it's obvious on his
shoulder
he's got a chip on his shoulder over
this stuff and regardless of how it pans
out in the
you know i i in the industry how it pans
out after everything is all the sudden
everything is out his goal was just that
like when he when he said we will not be
me
we're going to be bold
people people like say oh we know he had
to he had to sort of
kind of balance this this this this
train wreck of a ship that he
got handed right and people who will say
well he hasn't done anything right or
he's
very lucrative if we had to get to a
point where he could push his narrative
completely and this this is his box
right this is 100
his box he didn't have to sort of make
alterations to somebody else's ideas
and then run with that this is his right
and you see it like he's like i'm going
to make sure
that you can't say anything right you
can say
games whatever when it comes to the
machine you can't
there's nothing to say right and you can
you can have debates and back and forth
and
and we'll get into the topic
you can't say anything at the end of the
day people can say what they want in
this chat fanboys can argue as much as
they want at the beginning of the
generation they were getting killed in
power and there's no denying that
for every article you could say that
there wasn't anything i could breed up
five saying there was
uh he knew it's like it's like oh my i
cannot believe i'm about to say this
king was wrong
the whole generation was like all right
you got power we're going to take that
and he's like see what i had to do right
[Laughter]
you see what i had to do right you had
to put that onto something hat on
you see what it is right go ahead the
moment
the moment that they put the xbox at 1x
you did how often do you see anything
about resolution anymore
you never do and now they're going in
the next generation
it doesn't even matter if they have a
lock cart because they're going to have
the series x and what the series x is
going to do
is it's going to make sure that they
can't talk about power there's no
articles
on you he said how much is this a phil
and how much is it his team
like cindy walker who suggested the real
xbox series x at the vga
well i mean that's his team he literally
who hired them
regardless who does what it is still
phil spencer that
is approving the he he literally said in
that interview that he had with um
with the radio uh gamer radio
he literally said when she came in that
she he didn't like the ideal first but
he still went to the playstation again
he didn't like the idea at first but he
went through it because he
understood where she was coming from
right now
he had decided what's that though what's
that
i want i wanna hear it man what's that
that's a boss you know what he heard
you heard he said you know what you
wanted something man
you wanted something you know what yo
listen hey
go with what she said oh she knew she's
new what does she know
she's a
read the tea leaves around him you get
xbox one in 2013. that's right facts
that
that is tone-deaf to the message but
let's get back to will because he was
getting his points off
as far as what excited you you said
microsoft's coming out very dominant
you like the the aggression any specific
features that you saw from the tech
reveal had you excited sir
well lisa didn't ask me to send my
picture in my ears
[Laughter]
i'm gonna say the uh the fact that you
oh i don't remember what they called it
you can have multiple games in standby
mode
results and replays
because that comes in handy because i'm
in the uh the preview or whatever you
want to call it now
yeah i've been in it forever and there's
nothing worse than me in the middle of a
game
and you get an update yes yeah so you
get booted
yes absolutely extra when it boots you
from a game like it goes to the screen
it's like look we know you playing this
but you're doing this you ain't doing
that anymore
yeah well mine's set up to do it in the
background you know
at other times but it still does it
right when you're on it every single day
when you when you sign that paperwork
you know we will interrupt everything
right
that's why i had to get them all
shout out from microsoft for making my
call of duty xbox useless to me
no i'll figure it with me that is a
fantastic feature brother i agree man if
you finish i'll jump right in behind you
if you gotta get right ahead
yeah man listen man i mean super
impressive i mean let's just call it
what it is
he said from the marketing standpoint
how you know
we have boomers kind of salute move man
he's been he's had the faith more than
me yesterday i've
always been worried about marketing and
again when you get these stealth drops
it's been consistent
boom boom boom boom boom tech
information blogs full transparency
you know what i'm saying with the stuff
so um shout out to stitch uh sixty six
point twelve
chat the box was built to match the
upcoming games no doubt no doubt
look this is things out of it a lot of
it might have to do with phil two
because he is more
open to suggestions from his team than
necessarily maybe
other past you know leaders right
and and that's good leadership at the
end of the day when you you have you
take your ego out of it and someone
makes a good idea because
you said you know what let's let's go
with that if you think about it phil
what on a limb
for this chick that brought up that idea
because we're not talking like something
like you know kind of similar to what
you do we're talking about dropping
yo console reveal at the vga
and he approved that
it was the most exciting part of the
entire show let's be real okay nobody
cared about the past
yeah we were almost like yo like we were
still in shock but we'll be like when it
happened we were like
oh yeah well did that just happen like
what happened after the show
was going then they're going to get it
going and oh my god it was almost an
afterthought last year come face 23
he's back five out of ten i'm happy the
xbox team is taking risk
and being bold xbox wants this gen to be
already over
sony is ending the gym
we gotta do these extra man from now on
every time you got you two
argue we're go one of us is going to
read it because
cognito reading with his same voice both
we got to make it
interesting so i'm going to read
facebook every time when you read
the other no i got fakes i got faith oh
you got another one oh it's pissed yeah
i was talking about their argument not
not the oil guy okay
five dollars super chat for pixel bit g
xbox series x is so slow
it can resume five games at once use
machine
learning give you hdr even if you didn't
code it and cook
ponies at the same time oh my god
they messy today they're messy in the
row how do you feel about that face he
says he's cooking you at the same time
while he's playing state of decay and
looking at forza
listen man look at the end of the day i
get fantastic revealed hit i got some
key points that um
that stood out for me one again like
saab said
tangible tangible benchmarks evidence
shout out to digital fostering they had
the
gears 5 4k ultra settings with features
not even
in pc currently right now
initiative but wait check out game stack
check these side by load times hold on
this is how quick resume works
mind-blowing i'm sorry about that man
sometimes it gets so crazy that we
missed them yeah
sorry about that but yeah like i was
saying man like i said so i love that
they show gears 5
running on the series x benchmark two
week old bills off
not optimized right 4k 4 4k
um what is it 100 over 100 frames per
second you know what i'm saying with all
type of effects and some slight rate
tracing
and and super impressive so that that
right that's how you show a product to
people that's how you start
showing it off right we know this is
tech stuff but people want to see the
implementation what can it do
and again it's not even optimized not
even the full features and nothing
of the new features of the apoc none of
that really in it just yet so it's just
kind of a real bill so that's one
shout out to what addicts said with
austin evans that was huge because again
different perspective was cool to see
him break stuff down
you know what i'm saying do stuff like
that i love the switching like will me
was saying you know i'm saying now i
will say this but i don't know if that
applies because at first what he did
with state of decay
i'm like wait a minute state of decay is
always online how he able to do that
because normally
if that's like a game like destiny of
division you're going to get booted to
orbit if you're trying to resume yeah
yeah i think that's apparent people know
that that's about an online
title you're not going to be able to do
it like that facts i will say this
though i was
i didn't know state of decay had a new
feature since the juggernaut update to
turn that on off and make it like a
single player type game
by taking off the multiplayer so that's
how he's able to do with that but still
very impressive shout out to lord brad
sams
he was saying how that resuming stuff
that they're doing king
they're setting that up so that also
going to be part of
xcloud as well so like boom stop when
you're going to
pick up your safety right there in there
that quick resume that right there
i like the ssd stuff the talk they would
talk about how they're implementing that
um also how um dx12 ultimate solved did
you see about that dx12 ultimate bro
oh yes that that it's funny because we
always every generation we talk about
the secret sauce
are you ready are you ready for that
this is this is actually
real secret so finally
are you ready to talk about that because
let me tell you something they talked
about dx12 for a minute we've been
clowned and clowned and clowned and
clowned
see a lot of things y'all your thought
was jokes
like the power of the cloud how you feel
now
like sorry to interrupt you
tell me how kid smooth is going to
screenshot our super chat put it on
twitter
xbox x is so slow he can resume five
games up one two three
time to kiss moving his bag man yo we
got us
who would it get betty smith song you
want to get somebody smith find out
super chat
second let me go back in smitty smith
for the five dollar super chat salute to
all the gamers just
enjoy the games wherever you play gamers
gotta stick together because
as gamers we all win hashtags respect to
all
smack respect and you know we do got to
clarify that you know regardless what
the playstation is regardless the
backwards compatibility or the xbox
like the xbox is like almost
time like the series x is almost 10
times stronger than the regular xbox
yeah yeah i mean it's it's it's a huge
leap
all both of them even though even though
even the even the weaker playstation 5.
if they're both stronger don't give them
no praise yet no we're going
while you touch your shoulder as soon as
he turns back you hit him in the back of
the
head
out of control i'm gonna have to give
you a pause right there
with any man yes yes
with the with the gears 5 demo on how
they just able to implement ray tracing
from the bat without even with without
having to actually implement it
the what dx ultimate does is incorporate
all that
incorporate x-ray tracing and
incorporate vrs the very rate shading
shading um what is dx what is what is
dx12 ultimate sovereign
it's basically like an api no no no no
no no no okay he's not going to get what
i was
oh for amd
with nvidia uh in conjunction oh
so what does that mean so it means
everybody's in the bag
i mean it means the bag has been dropped
off to both
uh it is and um everybody
who's not in that bag i mean i just want
to know who's sitting at the big boy
table and who's looking up from the
little boy's seat talking about can we
get some fun too
are you safe
to this right when we in the playstation
conversation we'll get that in a minute
there was no talk of value there was no
talk of those features and there was no
deep learning super sampling yeah no
variable ratios
that everyone's eating in that big boy's
seat and it's sony's over there in the
booster seat like trying to reach the
food
what i'm trying to say is we back to
thanksgiving again fellas
and we're back at the big boys table and
it seems like somebody doesn't have a
seat
i'm just saying like so so at this table
where everybody's into this dx12
ultimate um
where's your man's hat i'm just trying
to figure out
what seat does sony have at this table
where big boys is playing around doing
big boy things
and i'm trying to figure out since they
did the little reveal
how come they ain't reveal a dx12
ultimate
like you're the defense king to you that
is the big question right now because
we know microsoft has been extremely
transparent you know with dx12 we i know
we don't get the playstation i got to
mention this part of placing like what
king said there was no mention like you
said solve
any of those dx12 ultimate features
apparently this is gonna be a complete
mesh so for the first time you know what
i'm saying the if your graphics card on
pc
has those features you'll have what the
series x is talking about
and vice versa it's that one-to-one
relationship so
those cards will take advantage in these
features and it does it appears
to see that that is not a feature that
uh playstation 5 have because they
didn't let me
talk about that for you oh lord let me
get it let me get it
get that for you man it goes back to
when it goes back to when people start
looking at okay which of these consoles
is going to be my third party console
right where i play
it it just looking at this from the
surface you say okay
they're gonna have an easier time
matching whatever a high-end pc can do
just the the the shared tech in the api
right right in a way that they've always
wanted it to be so but it hasn't
happened
remember at the start of this gen it was
it was
you know some people were using dx11
they were touting 12. not everybody used
12.
it was a long report
tell them out to my stand danny ruiz
that is
[Music]
someone please load up dreams and
properly reveal the piano
nintendo's the book of mine down yes
shut that down
the playstation is dead long live xbox
damn y'all popping bottles earlier
but look i'll just finish up real quick
and then we'll move on again all these
features tremendous you know real life
application which was dope
you know i'm saying everything it just
seemed like a perfect storm as far as
information
another point that nobody's mentioning
that i want to talk about was um
the latency modes how the controller how
they're gonna they're fixing all these
things to really
make that one-to-one relationship even
possible how important that is you know
what i'm saying especially with xcloud
and everything like that so i love that
and even the old controller
is going to get a firmware update to
match what the new xbox controller is
doing with that link
again finding ways to minimize latency
super impressive and they talk about
like how you the tv manufacturers
like so it's really dope is like you
know how like you could throw on game
mode and make
your latency go down but they're saying
with the new stuff like he's gonna
detect in your tv and
automatically put it in a game mode for
you doing all these latency steps
again this is very important for
incredible yeah one-to-one relationships
again as they
pioneer with with x-cloud and 5g
knocking down
barriers and hopefully next week we'll
tune in next week we may have something
very special in regards to that this
specific topic
so tune in to iop next week we should
have some special reference to that
okay so i got i gotta call it fair you
know what i'm saying because i gotta
play situation gonna be mad if i don't
say certain things but um look the only
negative
minor this is nick picking stuff you
know i love the heart rate chasing
see see king this is the cognito i don't
like
we should just go we should just go to
the next topic
don't get these playstation people what
they want
i like this cognito because this is the
cognito i can say stop that
let this cognitive go this is just
foolishness it really does scary this is
just my personal life
all right you know i love the ray trace
it it looked um it looked good it looked
really good
it's just i know how haters think
and haters will say yo well they only
got the ray tracing on that blocky
minecraft
why they thought if they threw it on
some fire it will blow up
come on you know how to dabble these
beats yes which is probably one of the
most visually
technically superior games of this
generation with what's going on inside
the game
anyone on pc will tell you that that
minecraft is not an easy game to put
right tracing on
yeah let's get it i got i just i could
say they said click of the button but um
let's get to the play fishing stuff
because i want to know what places
playstation did ray tracing
hold up i got chris hart reading from
the good book
welcome brother the book of
[Laughter]
to you the book of x you know what i i
the book of acts i like that
i got that right i'm surprised they try
to challenge our new emoji idea
hey but the the one i'm gonna give you
yeah they're gonna like that dude
i'm surprised like aaron greenberg came
up with the book of ex
that's a good one shout out to uh nobody
gonna let the king go i let the kid get
his balls our final point
the expandable storage right now
dope as far as the tech how you're not
you know you're going to be able to put
your games on there you're going to get
all the new features they should explain
the separation you can't put
your series s game on the old hard drive
i get that my only thing soft is
it kind of reminds me of the days the
proprietary memory card stuff
and i don't know how i feel i got to see
how that pricing will be
well i know this right the market always
finds ways to rectify this
yeah there are going to be plenty of
third-party
let's call them peripherals right yes
that will allow you to put
a regular nvme ssd in there and
connect it it's going to happen right
especially if the price is not right
right
especially if people want uh more than
one terabyte right and i think right
they're talking one term right now but i
think that's something that's going to
be it's going to it's going to grow
yeah it's going to grow it's going to
grow therefore when financially it's
exactly and this is the thing i don't
think
microsoft knows that that is a sticking
point for people
if you try to sell them this all this
extra um
memory at a ridiculous price people are
going to have
the stank face on well shout out to
booming them for saying 79.95
i believe it's going to be a buck 49.
we'll see i mean shout out to jess
gordon though he actually made a
counterpoint
right to my fear on xbox two he actually
said
that because they had cuz it looks like
they got the relationship with seagate
on that right so being that he said
because they
they made this exclusive deal and they
know that that level of ssd is so
far ahead and expensive that that
exclusive deal would get them to cut
a manufacturing cost yeah bring it down
at a lower price than what we think so
he's thinking it may be beneficial
that maybe the seagate gets that one
year or whatever it is exclusivity
that it's just their drives and then
maybe microsoft would approach them and
say hey
you got to bring that down so that we
can get the masses it might be 59.99
yeah we'll see i'll be sure
i hope i hope so yeah last but not least
it was amazing great piece of hardware
i'm telling y'all right now man i mean
this is an attractive
package and my pc there is a number this
thing blows my pc out the water
you know obviously we know pc catch up
eventually but for right now for the
value proposition
unmatched they they are killing it so
we're going to get into this smoke now
because i know uh king and everyone's
been waiting
for this part you know saying
playstation 5.
you know what i'm saying we got the the
tech reveal the deep dive
a lot of stuff going on you know what
i'm saying shout out to the cops i'm
going to pass it off right now
it cops the cops was on deck right now
as soon as i started talking about this
topic so um
let's get let's get will be to set it
off first um playstation 5
you are in our live reactions will mean
while this is going on
so let's get to it brother like what do
you think about the uh
mark cerny tech did uh deep dive about
what he talked about
i think mark cerny has a great career
when they make wayne's world forward
[Laughter]
i just could not get over the fact i was
waiting on getting that now isn't that
special
i'm done
[Laughter]
but the thing what i mean
i don't know man his speech
it didn't seem like it was made i mean
it just really did not feel like it was
it was designed for regular people to
listen to
but they knew this was coming up and
i feel like phil phil dominus had
pushed their hand they had to come out
with something at some point
because microsoft's been controlling the
narrative ever since you know
vgas hold on let me stop you so do you
think
this was a reactionary move cause some
have said oh yeah
oh cause somebody said no this was
playing the head and you know like so
you know
that main reaction no no this this was
react
i mean would anybody make that video and
put it down on purpose
i mean they probably they probably had
five people
quit filming that man i mean oh my god
you didn't appreciate the cut out crowd
you didn't appreciate
but you know what i looked at i looked
at it again and they're moving
yeah it's a nice animation to them all
right so
oh i'm sorry i gotta read this man so we
got a five dollar super chat from smitty
smith
chris hart said we mad but
he all in caps come get some of these
lamb chops
there's plenty of room at the table the
book of acts
we've been valerian five dollars in the
chat series x running path tracing
hardest version of race tracing this is
for smitty the book event
yo what is going on today what is
happening with the players
[Music]
continues continue let's get some x's in
that chat for the book of x i
i want that i don't want that let's get
some accents i would just
i personally hope this i mean i
hope this wasn't what they had actually
planned to bring out
people are saying this is for the gdc uh
audience
but i don't i don't know man
i just mark cerney it's it's really kind
of hard to take him seriously anyway
i know he's a smart guy i get that
i mean to talk the soft talk again
breaking down the tech
oh my god dude my dog even fell asleep
you know the only the only reason i
continued to watch it because i was on
your stream
the king had you rolling cause kick at
me right oh yeah i mean that was that
was the best part of the entire thing
did you partake in the back button
dictated that you have not partaken
we would like for you to press that back
button just a little bit more
pleasingly you know the greatest part
about that whole thing
is at the very end if you you know shout
out to our reaction go watch that man we
actually grew up a lot more than we
thought
wow we were watching i was in that
17 thousand views so we we were watching
that and i remember i'll never forget it
because i've seen this multiple times
you know we're sitting there at the very
end i'm like i'm like everyone be quiet
it's like this is the end they're gonna
surprise us they're gonna throw some
heat
kings like they ain't doing nothing
thank you they showed a couple seconds
of something and they're like
thank you and then we all just thought
we went crazy
when he started talking about the
overclocking and all this stuff and he
he did
you know talk about a little bit the gpu
and all this i'm like this doesn't even
make sense
so there's there's i don't know it's
just off
okay i just don't see it working out
like like he's trying to make it sound
okay so so just to clarify your main
issues obviously we
we all agree i think of the rev that it
was dry right as far as
the tone but my thing is i guess my
question to you is that did you
so the vibe i'm getting from you is that
you're
questioning even some of the techniques
and the stuff they talk about the
overclocking and
the uh maybe is there some of the stuff
you're questioning just be is it more so
because you didn't see real world
application or it's more so like nah fam
this just you know really
it does the job i mean it just i
actually found an article yesterday
i can't remember the name i'll send it
to you later after the show please do
yeah they they actually all these guys
do is review pcs
tablets stuff like that they're they're
leaving mess with gaming consoles
yeah and i was reading this article and
they were like this is such a joke
they were talking about the ps5 they
said it's just it's a terrible idea this
was
yeah they said there's no way this
thing's going to work and do what he's
claiming it's going to do
wow so okay let's smoke screen
i got to go before king because he going
i just got to say that man
addicts got to go before king okay cause
he's gonna take all attic stuff
addict oh it's my turn okay okay here we
go okay i didn't know what i thought
wilby was done
yeah go ahead okay get at it you ready
this
let's be real here we're going to have
to have some into the bushes
for this entire thing you know i and and
let me let let me attack the the people
on press start discord real quick okay
look salute the president you can't like
i had so many people
hey addict who's the gdc it's supposed
to be a ggc addict it was supposed to be
for developers
gdc addict gdc it's not for you it's for
them
hey hey king can i ask you a question
lord king can i ask you
did they present this at gdc well
being the gdc was closed
you know um my take the answer is
[Laughter]
are you inferring that when you you say
on your
playstation twitter account and then on
your youtube account
that that's not just for gdc that's for
a main audience that's what you would
like
i'm implying that when the event is
canceled the stream should have been
canceled
look i get it they still had this in the
bag i i get it they they didn't want to
waste all that it's probably
pre-recorded three four weeks ago to a
couple months ago but at the end of the
day
when there is not for those of you in
the chat that they're having
to check i'm sorry i got to read this
shout out to squirrely there 825
he said and phil said into the world let
me be 12
[Laughter]
save your ears from certain dolby cult
oh yeah
dolby called him out for his
misinformation on how many
channels dolby could do a lot of people
saying that 3d audio
was that they were talking about and
shout out to my boy um jean 37 37 in the
chat right now he's got a great article
on the ps5 audio situation
but dolby did refute lord certainly as
king calls him no that's magic mike
magic mike he's magic mike cerny
smitty smith two dollar super chat the
book of acts can be pre-ordered on
amazon
i understand they had this but my
thought process
is when they were going over this stuff
didn't feel like they already
like they would show something like this
once the console was announced
like like to me as a consumer
first you announce the console you
announce what it looks like
then you do this then you do this type
of stream
it's like look here's the call so for
those of you that want to know what this
console does in a breakdown
we got something for you this stream
he's going to break everything down on
it first off there's been multiple
people who's
who who king stan is on you he said
attic is
if not he could stay in that chat like
he would come back every week
and say all kinds of slanderous stuff
about me
but i don't see none of it because it's
not in color yeah let them talk in black
and white
anyway
[Laughter]
at the end of the day i get it this it's
like i said this is something they
should have showed
weeks after you know when you when you
dropped the actual x uh
not the xbox the playstation 5 this is
something you show right afterwards
they didn't do that they expected and
you know the dislike ratio
shows by itself sure we understand this
is for the developers
but there is to a point where when the
actual event is cancelled
they're like yo no one gonna understand
this man what do we need to do to make
this a little bit better
it's like oh cancel the whole thing and
look then we have to throw this whole
thing away i'm just
i'm disappointed by the way they went
with it
you know and this isn't even as bad if
we haven't went
so long without information on the ps5
it's been since like october
uh
[Laughter]
would you mind if i go to king now he's
yes
he's been waiting patiently the realm
has been wanting this
for so long shout out to willy hood that
is exactly how you get adam's attention
oh man i appreciate it
you in the podcast putting [ __ ] i
thought that was him
i forgot the
no no it's cool we got you okay shout
out to the 99 dollar
super chat from women this is how you
get addicts attention laugh out loud the
book of acts how about that is that fine
no excuses sony invited 15 000 clueless
fans to the tech talk
and gave them 24-hour notice to create
hype this was
a switcheroo worse than hunt the truth
that i don't know that hunt the truth
it's pretty bad i ain't going to lie
to you about that
book of x i want everyone to put book of
x at the end of the super chat
so you know the realm has been waiting
for this ball obviously
you know you were a superstar highlight
live reactions but before
we talking we got to point out that
there are a couple things that
people in the industry are second
guessing
you know uh what was presented in their
thing you know you guys said earlier
that dolby was second guessing didn't
albert from edo say
some stuff too yeah albert palello had
questions
about um tobacco ability
and um he he as far as the variable
aspect of um yeah about the thing
okay it's deployed
so we also magic mike cerny
get up there boy and i told y'all the
day before right i said i said yo
i said mike is gonna get up there magic
mike
he's gonna get up there with his little
magician trick we're gonna show you less
say even less you walk away thinking you
got everything
and i saw so many sony dudes out there
talking oh my god yo it's so
fast
from power to speed it was like a matter
of like an hour
it changed from power to speed on
twitter
it ain't changed have a small
ssd pulse
hey it's not the size that matters right
it's how you use it what's going on oh
my god
we do got to bring up that weird 820.
if anybody told you that they're
absolutely lying
if anybody looked you in your eyes and
told you that they just wanted to make
you feel better
i've been told from very from very uh
various sources that
ladies like it as fast as possible oh my
god what are we doing
what are we doing today this is the
lord's day man
look at this conversation king has
initiated okay
continue king is better than nine oh man
any of these dudes out here telling you
is quick this is nice to be quick
let's cut that out let's stop magic was
out here he was doing his little parlor
tricks and y'all fell for every last one
of them
but uh also magic mike to see
everybody's all upset about this whole
uh
reveal thing that they showed they told
you yo tomorrow
you'll see we're gonna get out there
and then mike got up there and said hi
guys
i want you to all sit down and just give
me photos of your ears
at 17 years old he made his games
and the fact that he's he's a genius
he's in his own world you was in the
magic world of mike
and he wrote there's no loud speaking in
mike's world so don't don't think he was
gonna get that you was gonna get what he
wanted to give you
he wanted to tell you the philosophy of
the box going forward
so the philosophy of the playstation 5
as i see it as he presented to us
on the stage on the podium
was a very over charged machine
oh it is unstable
it's unstable this length credence to
what i was hearing in the background
talking about the dev kits
were sounding like they had jet engines
in them
and it was running really loud so i
didn't understand
what they were saying when it's pushing
that that past that nine point two that
they
when you take in a nine point two and
you're over
you're stretching it to its absolute
limits right and you're doing it the
same thing with the gpu
you're stretching this thing way beyond
what it is and it's
cost cutting measures because now you're
telling the box it has to juggle
well when the box has to juggle now you
got a little circus clown in your room
oh dude
is there a hamster in this thing what's
going on
well when when it has to do cpu stuff
it's juggling
with the right hand but then it's just
yo we need a graphical explosion
balls over here to the side what happens
if it drops
happens in the system they tell you that
it reverts back to its base form
it slows down there's too much heat in
that box
so we don't know anything about the
coolant system
they have the vapor chain cooling the
head
facts they're gonna have the huge free
energy did you see how big that fan was
the fan was bigger than the motherboard
yeah you said that was huge for the
seriousness yes okay so now and that's a
stable box
if you notice they put stuff in the
series x to a way where
you know when that fan goes through it's
going through all those components
right so they they gave you a stable box
and they got a huge fan
and they got teeth sinks all over the
place and they got a paper cooling
chamber
right so you see this this is what you
see this is the problem that i had
with the fake gdc thing is
what it is it turned into a fake gdc
thing because there was no gdc
and i'm not gonna say that sony wasn't
presenting this at gdc i'm gonna take it
at face value yes this was for
shareholders
this is to get the money up right this
is to actually
get you some silicon together because
usually at this time in the game
you have a disc you have you have a
chipset
that you're actually walking around and
showing or
or you have a form factor so the fact
that they didn't
decide on a form factor or they can't
decide on the chipset or they don't have
anything to show you at this point in
time
gives me fear so you can
launch on time but back to
what you know magic mike was talking
about
he's probably throwing you curveballs
and misdirections he started reaching
over your head then he started telling
false truths that dove you have to call
him out on
him so the next day without it was a
nightmare it was it was
yeah for him because he was telling
false truths
not talking about i want to understand
where's this tempest 3d
crap that they're talking about like is
that a real audio thing or is this
something that magic mike made up
all right so mike that's not his real
name
his name is not magic real quick let's
go ahead and get the super chat so you
can continue
uh you know your your gossip man i i i
want to hear this but we got to finish
this real quick
we got to fight all this super chat from
smitty come on chris hart be
reasonable they gave the series x to
digital foundry
it is 12 teraflops of power the book of
x
okay continue kicking then we gotta get
up
i just want to say this right it's it's
a nice ssd
right but all developers is going to uh
cater to the least common denominator so
if the
the if that's your strength they're
going to cater to
because they have to make these games
work across the board so now we're
looking at first
party development right and that's where
the ssd is going to shine
but how many games are you going to get
on this ssd
right because you don't have a full one
terabit how much
of that ssd is being used
by the user interface
see the allocation in the box is wrong
i do want to point out king there's a
lot of things that that
their communication is horrible it's not
just this
ssd i'm confused on backwards
compatibility exactly how many games is
on this
you know they go from in launch to when
they were talking in the
you know the actual you know the stream
that uh
mark did and then uh you know their
their reaction to
people and then two days later they go
from launch to
there'll be four thousand games playable
on the ps5 like
they go from launch to ps5 so i'm
confused on that too
i mean people okay by the end of the
life cycle you'll be able to play 4 000
games
i think that's what it is people are
taking that like there's four thousand
games out the box that's going to be on
this is when you rip a hope away from
someone
you know when you throw somebody in the
middle of the ocean they will grab a
piece of doodle
floating in the water to stay afloat so
this is exactly what they're doing
they're grabbing
any floating feces to stay alive
listen i totally understand it i i
totally get it
the heart was broken you thought you
were gonna come in that day you thought
that this is the day that playstation
suns these
xbox dudes and it's over 13 teraflops
and we're gonna kill y'all
i get a bunch of little minions i don't
know the top sony dudes in my mentions
no more
because they're fearful of the wrath of
king
oh before with phil dominus maximus
spencer soon to be aurelius
is doing to you it's disgusting
it's real messy now okay i just want to
ask one question before we move forward
so
clearly you feel this is a marketing
misstep that's number one you you feel
that because a lot of the sony bass
start coming in
a lot i i was watching twitter and a lot
of people would say look as far as the
teraflop look
right there was rumors of the 13 or the
15 or the 25 or
the million is when we put it in his
tweets you know what's it
and you know that was the first bubble
to break so to speak in reference to
what you're saying
but i want to i want to talk about the
marketing part like
do you feel you you honestly feel like
this was their they thought they were
gonna clap back
and then it was just like what do you
feel you think this is a what do you
categorize this this is a marketing
mistake what do you what do you feel
about what happened
regardless you got on your best clothes
and you get out the car and you slip and
you fall
you got all your best clothes so you say
he got out the car slipped on that mud
and now his whole clothes is covered in
mud
you you have on your best clothes and
the bus ran past that puddle and
splashed you
yes you you you you you you thought you
fought it but then you shot it
you wanna oh damn this is
this is what they did yo you remember
the time roy jones was beating the
brakes off of one fighter
so bad he went over to ref and said yo
save this dude
get him off me xbox is roy jones right
now and they beating the brakes off
these dudes and they talking about your
ref come in save these dudes
because y'all thought the game was going
to be shown and you know what he said
and this i'm going to tell you what he
said because i'm finished with my
segment too
thank you
[Laughter]
let me make sure okay we got a five
dollar super chat again from smitty
smith
man it looks like it hit it looks like
he beaten these playstation people ain't
nobody correcting him anymore
so ps fanboys power doesn't matter but
here we are
xbox you do not have it the book of acts
all right so we got some uh saudi realm
in the building
shout out to lord babbitt for making his
return
for the cameo so real quick batman
obviously we got to get it from the
playstation nation right yeah
i don't know don't know we got to get
somebody what was your first
thing this week yeah um wow
a lot of feelings first of all thank you
for having me on i was literally just
playing dude maternal
no doubt my god i'm in love with that
game uh
secondly uh my my thoughts as of
what am a happened
believer and i and i mean this
wholeheartedly let's go at the end of
the day there's only two things that
matter when you're selling a console
power is not one of them
it comes to the games and services that
you are bringing
and then first and foremost is the
messaging
messaging matters that's the only thing
that really matters at the end of the
day
because if power mattered the nintendo
switch would be out of the question of
the equation
out of here thanks to me walking in
there
sony did a piss poor job of messaging
there's no there's no argument to be had
xbox
phil dominus maximus has been
killing it ever since just dropping the
name of the console
the way it looks right then and there in
december at the game awards
getting you already accustomed to the
weird name
the weird but awesome looking box and
then showing you
games or cutscenes whatever we're going
to call them right there
live in front of you showing the power
showing how awesome
this console is going to look like they
have been doing a
fantastic job messaging
and on pr now has there been some some
you know slip-ups when it comes to the
backwards compatibility
sure but man other than that microsoft's
been killing it
and i give them huge props for for what
they've
been so aggressive this past year i
gotta disagree with you on one oh oh
oh oh like i've always been crazy you
disagree
i've always been one point that you know
power doesn't matter but i do feel to a
point it is a selling matter when it
comes to third party
look at stuff like red dead you know uh
you know it doesn't happen with
everything
but when a highly anticipated third
party game comes out let's say cd
projekt red
with their game let's say that came out
around launch about maybe a week after
launching it ran
drastically better on the series that's
because of the power difference
i think that would matter because you
had people on twitter
that i'm gonna stop you right there
check the sales numbers of both of those
games it doesn't matter we're talking
about the perception the messaging that
you were just
saying we didn't bring themselves at all
no no no i mean
i understand what exactly what uh a bad
bit is saying
um power doesn't matter when you go into
the least common denominator and then
you go into sales and messaging it's key
because messenger is exactly what did
microsoft and
people know they're not deleted right
now it does matter at the start of a
generation and
if it's any time where it does matter is
to start just because of the messaging
right you're trying to convince people
to move over to another
and spend another 500 hours only gonna
matter if they are the same price tag
then they are on technically as you're
looking at it
equal firms right to me what matters for
xbox is the way they've been leading the
conversation
and they've been leading uh leading
everybody
to them of how amazing what amazing
things they're doing
again they're not the market leader but
they're acting like it that's bullish
that builds confidence
and that's what people are starting to
look for now with that said walking into
this
i knew exactly what we were going to get
i knew exactly how cringy was going to
be
because this is not something that has
never happened
this happens all the time when they're
putting out new content whether that's
playstation 4 pro or the playstation 4.
yeah let me say something before you say
something yeah
the reason i'm saying that you know
it wouldn't come
i saw people working at ign saying that
they
were considering restarting the game
because it looked different
okay it's just like it's just like the
you know the ssd
if you know that feature works the way
that everyone says it works
that's gonna matter because if you
eliminate any type of load screens from
anything let's say that
you have the same game you have
cyberpunk and you have it on the
playstation you have on the xbox let's
say the ssd works the way it is and
there's no loading screens on the
playstation
that's gonna matter because word of
mouth really pushes twitter and these
days we're more into social media than
we were in 2013.
i totally understand what you're saying
i'm totally i'm not thrown out all out
what i'm saying is messaging matters the
most out of everything
it does like if you care about power
this is what you're getting right here
look at this beautiful
[Laughter]
shout out to the pc masters race
here's the thing though walking in i
knew what we were getting
i already felt like it was a mistake
because when they
when they launched a ps4 mark cerney did
one of these talks
and everybody didn't really listen to it
because we already saw the
intro of the playstation 4 the real
start where they showed you kill zone
and all that uh yeah that's good
you had reference to the power that mark
cerny was talking about
yes thank you for saying that and here
you don't have anything to reference all
you had
and and and i knew this was gonna be an
issue when i was i was streaming this
with my co-host i go what do you expect
he's like i think we're going to see uh
horizon zero dawn too
you guys caught dinosaurs i was there i
was cause it's not gonna happen
no but the reason i thought that is
because not because they were doing this
it's because
of the timing the timing of that i was
like because sony has been a very
reactive company this whole generation
and i thought that they were waiting for
those speeches before
because they've been i got to jump in on
this too because because
i again was kind of in attic's boat as
well also because we know mike
like you said babbitt microsoft has been
so bullish right they've been putting
out all this information
and it's almost like almo this is what i
felt solved i was almost like you know
what
i've been talking too that much you know
what i'm saying like we're the leaders
we got to make people
understand that we coming you know so it
to me
it was like they could have put that
video out any other time
but it was right the next day right
before
you know microsoft did this huge
explosion with digital files and all
that stuff it was almost like oh
they may edit something right change
something
up or add a little piece to whatever
this thing is you know i'm saying
and i agree with you i agree well last
part but i'll give it back to you
is that you made a good point as far as
you know what you're worried about
coming into
the thing i felt was i knew obviously we
knew mark sonny was going to be in there
right
but it was one of those things that you
almost
felt that they had something to show
in conjunction with him being there and
that's the thing that's really
disappointing again
before anybody calls me a sony pony look
at this
we know you right now
are you in the chat that i'm in that got
the message like the day before exactly
what was gonna happen
uh no okay okay okay
but knowing knowing sony the way i do i
knew
we were in for a treat uh we get so
let's let let's get to super chat real
quick before you go
so we got five dollar super chat from
smitty smith chris hart out here
fighting plastic wars
hashtag the at the book of acts look at
that we got we missed a couple
challenges g
mark lewis two dollar super chat sony
was shopping from the value menu for the
ps5
and then sweetie smith two dollar super
chat
let's give it up for cat locks chris
hart what you gotta say
for man the book of acts you gotta say
quick book of mine yeah
we give it to them anyway continue bad
bit let's go so yeah um
the first mistake was they let they live
stream this instead of just
putting a video out there yeah right
they're like if they want to just put
your video out there
that was a lot it would have been way
better it was live we did a live
reaction
no no no you don't care
because when people are coming in there
the video is not starting at the
beginning
where jim tap dancing ryan looks like he
was
pooped after like dancing foreign
because he walks out
tired and disheveled and he states hey
this was a speech we were going to have
at gdc
but he's been canceled because of what
we know
he's mark cerny and he's going to talk
to the mystery science theater folks for
about 50 minutes
and from then on i was just like okay
this is i
now i know what we're getting we're
getting a dev we're getting a dev talk
and unfortunately sony pr and social
media
teams marketed as oh we're gonna see
something
thank you
yeah the messaging and what actually was
supposed to happen
were two totally different things every
day marketing did him
no favors come see the future of the
playstation 5.
come see the next generation of gaming
how it's going to transform and all that
and then you bring him out
to continue baby i got a lot of denmark
trinity's out there going
hello everyone
i want to collect your ears send me
pictures
of your ears
pictures from my development friends
they're just like this could have been
cut in half because i know how a hard
drive works
and then from just the regular folk like
me people are like
this could have been cut down by at
least 20 minutes this should have been a
just a digital foundry video video which
the guys
uh of digital foundry came out they said
sony was supposed to be there with them
right
to make something to collaborate with
them but again what happened
uh you know down with the sickness
happened
i don't know i don't buy that i believe
they don't have any silicon or anything
to show
so if if you know i think they actually
have a product to show they just have
yeah
they just have data using a spreadsheet
right now yeah you know microsoft
um has all this stuff to show
they had it to show there and and you're
not going to walk up
and don't have anything to show i'm
sorry i i understand
mark turner will definitely get if you
talk to them on the phone and tell them
what the direction is
i just i honestly in my heart i've
seen this so much i don't believe
they have silicon i think i think
they're still in the prototype
phase of i i think they're still they're
still finalizing design not prototype
same with the playstation 4 where the
artist didn't know that his
uh model of the police was picked
i think they haven't picked a form
factor of this console yet
wow and that's why they don't again this
wasn't for us to reveal
these consoles in a normal world these
consoles
are going into production by late may
early june period
for for for holiday release there's no
way they don't have a form factor
there's no way they don't have to
so that's all said and done the mistake
is that they
they chose not to show it right right
let me let your
true for one second solve so you know
the the biggest question people have
been asking
is it possible that maybe the
playstation's been is going to get
delayed
yeah even if it gets delayed even if
there's a good stream
no matter who says what like that's the
real like that's the
that's the realism of this whole thing
but we talked about playstation right
now
yeah i mean it's delayed into the first
quarter of next year
they know what they're i don't think
it's i don't think they do that if they
get delayed regardless if both of them
or one of them get delayed
they're both going coming out holiday
next year i don't think they're going to
just launch a console at the beginning
of the year
guys yeah what is delayed to
what i'm saying is that what's going
into that box is set in stone already
right yeah they've been able to up some
clock speeds of this that and the other
beyond that
was going into the boxes set so they
have to have that right
you're gonna tell me that just because
of what's happened over the past three
months
it's they're so backed up that they
don't even have
the form factor of the machine they
don't even have the actual cell phone
they're going to put into it whether
they're
at the level that they want to that's
the the question is why
are they reluctant to show even
intangible benchmarks so like if it's a
text
if it's a tech only show the way bad bit
is saying and i'm fine with that and
this is where
i struggle with you know my playstation
brothers or the sense of this
people like this wasn't for you this was
supposed to be attacking yadda yadda
that was a mistake but here's my problem
with the mistake
right if you're gonna say you're gonna
just do that fine right
but even when they did playstation 4 pro
right you have tangible thing even if
you show
spider-man or if you compare it to
yourself
yeah about what that's the problem
there was no physical benchmarks no
tangible evidence of all this
theoretical stuff
that me and will me have issues
believing
you don't do yourself any favor if this
tech is all it is right it is the
realest thing in the world
right your fans would like to see it i
would love to see it
i totally get that cognito and i'm right
there with you
they told us they didn't show us the
only thing that we
have is shaky cam footage of spider-man
from a year ago
thanks do you think all this what's that
what they messed up in is it and
everybody has said it to some extent
is that they took what was they took
their gdc presentation as is right and
decided that the best move was to
release it to the world
yeah and rather than say you know what
send that same
presentation send it to all the devs let
the dev see it right yeah that's
when it's going to come out online
people everybody will get a chance to
see it right at the same time
create a consumer-facing presentation
distills all this information to
something that's easily
uh uh digestible and understandable to
people who don't care about
mark cerny's vision
what it could do they don't care about
how mark's certainly because listen mark
cerny
99.9 of the time when he opens his mouth
he's the smartest
dude in the room no one's gonna know
what he's talking about exactly he's
going another level when he thinks about
this stuff
and that's cool but it does not apply
to 90 of the people that are gonna buy
this it's kind of like you have a steve
wozniak making all the apple computers
and then you have a steve jobs who's
selling it
let me talk about this like this i think
the biggest case here
uh you know it was a podcast i listened
to i can't remember what podcast it was
but he brought up a good point
he said that he thinks what's going on
here is uh the change of leadership
uh he says you know not you know when
mark cerny came up and he's like i want
to drop this video or the marketing team
said that
you know maybe because of the change of
leadership people don't know who to go
through to override people people don't
know to go to you i don't think this is
a good idea
there's been a drastic change of
leadership but it's like
they've been doing this from the launch
of ps4 they did it before
the only thing was like that was for the
launch of ps4
no longer there right but it the same
they did the exact same thing though
cerny came out and like babbitt said
like
it it didn't affect the way it affected
now because you haven't already had
when the because four was revealed they
revealed the controller
two months before this mission so the
people so discerning weirdness didn't
land it
as hard during the weirdness
[Music]
that's what we're doing who had context
you had other things like all right i
already seen this this is certainly
you know in his in his mind giving us
the bridge for something that none of us
are really gonna understand
but we already know what it is we have
exactly we'll get to your super chat
kids smooth calm down i got i'm gonna
get kid
i'm a good kid let me let me take care
of it because everybody wait kissable
followers
thermal issues cooling we are way behind
well let me get this one then y'all can
catch the ones i miss thermal issues
cooling issues form factor not finalized
the ps5
and its inefficient design is red ring
of death in the lab
and i just gotta get slow-motion i
believe real quick because i i agree
with you
guys we gotta talk about super chats
before starting all right but let me get
my bro
if you want to say it was just for the
devs then why promote it on twitter and
put it on your youtube channel a day
before microsoft did they
that's my exact point now you get the
rest of your chat that's right so we got
uh we got a five did anyone read the
philly eagle one
no no okay we got a five dollar super
chat from philly eagle
for all my gamers out there keep gaming
where and how you want and thank you for
not
having a war on captain lock button
salute
lords then we gotta find all the super
chat from i am not even trying
super poetic x initiative there you go
that's how long
okay from now on he is pronouncing your
name because i'll never do that
so question is how many strikes would
the community give sony would they
take a page from the chapter 2013
the book of x i do kind of agree with
them like
like not necessarily just from this one
but how many of
you know these kind of incidences are
we're going to keep giving them but
before we
go into that we got more we got more
super chats uh we got the kids smooth
one
then we got the five dollar smitty
schmidt if you show something that
wasn't for the public then don't
advertise it so therefore
you are subject to public uh efficiency
the book
x shout out to jd gave a five dollar
super chat late to the show
but i have to know is the difference
between the xbox series x and
playstation 5's ssd so
fast that it will affect game design or
games running correctly look all i can
say we simply don't know right now
we don't know but there's speculation on
on both sides and shout out to jason
schreier he said that it's a
revolutionary piece of tech people are
saying shout out to john lennon people
say that it basically just tries to say
it's so revolutionary they're so upset
that devs was internally so upset with
sony
and the fact that it wasn't presented
and marketed correctly
because they're saying the consensus is
everybody walked away from
that the mark sorry thing saying like oh
wow it's the inferior thing and not
getting
the full application of how this thing
is supposed to be changed in game from a
data transfer standpoint
i know linnerman has went in on that as
well shout out boy letterman from
digital foundry
he said that i quote he was saying he
said the craziest thing about is the
speed is that it's more to the story
he said if the system isn't bottlenecked
in other areas it's really fast on paper
he said a lot faster than the series x
even he said it's not about load times
it's about accessing data super fast on
the fly
it can change how worlds are designed he
said it's a fundamental
shift so that's where he's at far p
there are people who are excited
about the town gotta give it back we're
just gonna have to see exactly how
that's played out
and that's the thing a lot of a lot of
people have come to me because on the
latest episode of the trophy room
i had uh benji sales on we were kind of
trying to dissect this thing because we
were both kind of confused and
bewildered at
why they would market it and everybody
you know the the one super chat's right
if you promote this like it's hey it's
here for everyone
then yeah that is confusing and yeah
that is a strike
on playstation's behalf the thing is
for me the the true problem is
it's been the day after the morning
after i woke up to
so many messages going hey joe um just
want to let you know this is how
actually the systems are
you know side by side from each other
and actually then developers coming out
going
actually no this is actually really
awesome like the
this is this is awesome tech this is
amazing that usually we're on the back
of the line and it looks like now
finally we're in the front and we're
we're getting attention on us and it
does come down to the fact that um
you know what it seems like is
playstation is
playstation xbox are in two awesome
positions like they're actually doing
something different for once
right right it was like where xbox is
saying hey
do you want the best looking thing it's
gonna be fast
but it's going to be looking the best
right you want probably true 8k
it's gonna be here where playstation's
like hey listen
do you want the fastest thing do you
want more updates do you want no more
load times right they want to get it
back to
the snes days you plug a cartridge into
your system
and it works like that there is no
loading there is nothing and if we're
taking the spider-man
shaky cam as any indication it went
six different locations in under a
second right
now listen let me go upside down and
that's
impressive but you guys are all right we
should have saw that
it's just a windows xp you know
screensaver
instead of like predator vision
stuff and it's so hard to like and i get
the the predator vision and mark
certainly wanting pictures of you can i
say
can i say one thing yeah if microsoft
stuff never happened
are we touting this as good
because see you know you have to
benchmark this in front of it right so
the bar was set at such a level
that how could they clear that level
unless they had
uh surpassed it they had to show you
tech
they had to show it to you in the same
manner that microsoft showed it to you
that had to show you games i heard
people say i got to see god fall running
on the playstation 5.
you know oh oh i got to see zero horizon
dawn or horizon
or whatever and uh i want to see i want
to see god war too
you know like outrageous things
the expectations was at a at a point
where mark cerny could no matter what he
could do yeah that's why i said casey
walker and did him no
favor it's really not his fault we know
he's going to be in his bag
we know he's going to talk his tech he
loves this
that man didn't trip over his words oh
he is a genius you're a philosopher okay
he he he's he
he's a genius you understand i don't
i'm not gonna understate the fact that
the man was making video games at the
age of 17.
okay he's a certified genius
all right so every time he goes into the
room he believes that he's the smartest
person in the room
facts all right so what he was doing was
his his calm demeanor talking to you was
he was trying to explain it to you in a
manner that he felt that just
simple-minded individuals
will be able to get confidence ending
that's why he was
trying to god appreciate that with me no
but i'm telling him i just thought it
was funny
yeah this is that's what happens how do
you talk to your child
when they're not listening that's what
you listen to you were being talked down
to a little bit right like
the whole time i was talking about that
life works this way
right right it's not fluctuating
what it will do is have a constant
stream
can you can you see do you see the
stream look at the wall
i've got all my ears
at the end of the day if they're going
this much into detail about stuff that a
lot of developers already know
i mean you had developers come out
openly and say that like
do you think this was a hundred percent
for developers then like
yes yeah and i think what king said
really killed it here which was you know
if xbox did the same thing or just did a
digital foundry video
i think the bar would have been set
differently but because they gave us
something technical for for the devs for
people that really give a crap about it
right
that was the digital foundry video and
then they got you know cute boy
chris evans over here whatever what's
this guy austin evans
he's in his bag he got attic to watch he
he's there and he's putting it in
english for everybody else he's pulled
off something special if you get me to
watch something
attic hates listen they're talking about
tech he just wants to see stuff
you got him excited but like that's the
thing that's that was
how xbox has been so on point with
messaging and that is their
biggest advantage coming into next
generation
is how they're able to tell the devs
what they need to hear
and then give something separate for
people that really
care about it but don't know tech like
the way that developers do
and deliver two different packages for
people that
at the end of the day everybody was
happy right like i was happy i mean like
things like machined learned ray tracing
my mind that's awesome that's game
preservation that's something
everybody should be championing and not
enough people are because we care
too much about teraflops and we don't
care about hey
you know what there's original xbox
games that need to be preserved and how
do we do that
we do that with the power of the xbox
users absolutely let me get this to the
checker
and then i'll finish up jd game with
file super chat if microsoft wanted to
do a late
cycle speed bump much like the xbox one
bump it is possible to ramp the clock
speeds and add those four gigabytes of
memory
up to 20 gigabytes that's possible we'll
see if they implement this stuff so we
want to finish up and then i'll jump
right behind you and we move on
yeah i mean listen my thing with this
what i'm worried about with this system
is right
the last generation we touted both
machines for coming out with machines
that were not
crazily like over um r d
bespoke consoles that that that made it
difficult for developers
it was another hurdle right they they
finally got it to the point where they
made them as easy to develop for as pc
so there was some uniformity across the
board right
and the expectation was that beyond all
the power leaps we're getting right
and innovations in that regard the
expectation was that was
to continue in order to to make it so
that
once again that that delta between pc
and console
is less and less right and we see what
microsoft is doing in that regard
with with the x and with dx uh 12
ultimate stuff like that
i look at the ps5 i i certainly hope
everything they're talking about works
i certainly hope so that would be
amazing the question is when i look at
these features
it makes it makes me think of another
console oh
and that console's the ps3 the fiesta i
knew he was going to say that you know
who said that too
shout out shout out the whole hulk said
the same thing you said soft
he said that he's just worried he's not
saying that
yeah cell chip because again sometimes
when you go too theoretical with the
talk
and you don't see the real world
application
people question the message right and if
this thing could very well do all these
things solve world peace
and hunger right but at the end of the
day if you don't demonstrate the
capabilities
you have now put questions in the heart
of your base
they are looking at you with the soda i
need to see
you know what i'm saying and that's what
let me just tell you because i got some
questions
okay because it's beyond demonstrating
it though right
the thing with the ps3 that it made it
difficult for
anybody but first yeah good point good
choice
to extract the most out of that console
right
it's when you when you make comparisons
with third i don't care i don't care
you when you talk about first party
right sony first party is off the chain
right
it is what gives the identity to
playstation
right what sells most across the board
across the entire generation is
third-party games yes if
you're third because of how different
the ssd works
give me five seconds uh chad do you
still hear us
because on obs is saying that uh it's
not yeah
no it's still they live they don't see
you know how obs
so my worry is that yeah first party
will get
the full to use fully 100
right and those games will look amazing
right right third party
people are going to have that's the
question when you're making that's the
question
three and if you're still making them
for last gen right
so you're talking about you know four or
five skus of the game
do you not take the hard drive as much
as the consideration when you have to
worry about making five versions of the
game
i think that's those are good questions
that we'll need answers to
to me i'm not concerned about that uh
and just because of how my gerbil brain
works
i believe ps4 is x86 architecture so is
the
playstation 5. so i don't think they're
going to have a cell processor problem
no if they have they're really trying to
nail down to developers
about ease of use i think both xbox and
i don't have an
uh any problem with xbox either i've
both xbox
and sony have learned that their uh
playstation rather
have learned that hey let's not
complicate it for developers let's just
make it as easy as possible because
you know xbox one had that sram yeah
yeah
three you have the cell processor
absolutely okay so i'll finish up
the question that i have is that if the
hard drive
is that game changing right
it becomes a money issue with a third
party right do we invest in utilizing
this
to its utmost ability or we dumb it down
a little bit
right so that it works across all
platforms like and i mean like i said
maybe xbox one so the thing is do you
are you not able to extract the very
best out of it
because of how bespoke that is to that
console to that console
and it's up to sony to do a great job of
messaging and relaying to these third
party developers
ease of use and it's all about shout out
to optimus code he was on um
brap i believe a couple days ago um just
the the tools if you if you make these
developer tools
easy to implement and accessible you
know i'm saying
that's gonna be the key we have to find
out that information because a lot of
devs are kind of upset with certain like
yo you're not talking about
how cool this tech is and da da da da so
again a little misstep there
i want to get this jd gamer huh i said
is that fearfulness
that they're not getting the message out
and they're seeing the missteps and
they're worried
that if they put their eggs in this
basket because they're making games for
them
and they put this egg in this basket and
it's not marketed properly did they bet
they horse they chip on the wrong horse
this the pony that they they they put
money on
and it's not right i mean i mean if i go
and i put my money down on something and
you're not marketing it properly
and i've i sunk my money into your
company i'm gonna get kind of pissed off
if you're not talking about the cool
tech that you you showed me in the back
room
don't need a cool tech you know show the
people the cool tech man
i mean they're the market leaders so i
mean they still can't be too scared yet
but i can understand the frustration
real quick jd gave down jumping jd gave
a file super chat bad bit
what is your opinion of the velocity
engine six gigabytes compared
to the playstation five ssd eight to
nine the x
series x compression is two to one
versus playstation fives
one to six to one compression and yeah
like part two
certainly five dollars certainly
mentioned cell spu like qualities in the
tempest engine
will this make it difficult for
developers and
will these spu like qualities allow
backward three compatibility
so break it down tech genius mr um
i ain't no tech genius a lot of that
everyone
out together and i'm dazed and confused
so um
i'll i will say this uh no developer
that i've seen online
is showing any worry about how difficult
this thing seems to be
coding for maybe you could point me into
that uh to the right direction but
no developer is looking at it going uh
this seems hard right
yeah a lot of people are are what like
the gang here says
where it's hey talk about how awesome
this tech is like
talk about the 3d sound like talk about
that hard drive stuff
we want to know more about it it seems
pretty rad
so when it comes to the tech inside
it's all the way it's it's all and
that's it sucks because it's asking us
to be so patient
after what had already been a disaster
way to or a disastrous way
to start the place this is a huge bump
in the road
this is something though i am if i'm
sony right now and i
and i you know i could read the
temperature in the room and i think
what we're what we're seeing here is
we're nervous
because we just came out and we just
stripped on ourselves we got out of that
nice car we got out of the nice
you know and right face planted bruce
wayne does a face plant he just comes
out and
everybody all eyes on him so yeah i
think
everybody at sconey knows they actually
need to start showing something of
substance soon absolutely
because that patience is now turning
into doubt
and i don't blame anybody for going hey
is sony nervous is this that the other
thing because
maybe who knows right they left
themselves open to that kind of
criticism exactly
dragon wolf two pound super chat will
sony ssd do any difference to call of
duty man
it's up to them good at it um
did we get the ones above that the pixel
no we didn't get
okay so we got a a pixel bit g
uh five dollar super chat pc devs who
target multi plates
aren't going to use it unless pcs also
have the
s hdd right on the other hand dx12
ultimate ain't to make xbox desks the
same as pc
yeah that's correct let me let me let me
talk about that ssd real quick there's
no ssd on the market that can actually
do what they're talking about
okay so um that's where the the problem
lies
maybe they're too far ahead of the curve
when it comes to this ssd drive
right i'm not taking anything away from
it i'm gonna have the system and i'm
truly happy that
their first party development studios
would definitely utilize this tech
but at the same time if it can't be
used inside a pc form it's not going to
be used
because i don't care what you say
there's going to be video cards that's
going to blow this stuff out the water
by the time they hit the market the next
video cards will be out
and microsoft is placing itself in a
position where
that uh direct 12 ultimate
is in position you know for later on
applications and so it can scale down
the boards
sony's in a unique position and y'all
keep saying market leader
there's no market leader at the
beginning of a generation
okay so you're starting fresh it's
called a fresh slate cleveland
you're not coming in with your with your
baggage unless you got back compatible
obviously we understand who does so you
don't want to have that level of
conversation
going into the next generation when
you're really not bringing your heart
with you
you just bring in a couple of guys right
this is what you're doing
so in the beginning of the next
generation this is why this stuff is
real scary and real spooky in the
beginning
because any misstep and you can no
longer be
champion you can be dethroned so
i'm not saying and and this is wishful
thinking on my part
okay i feel that i respect i want y'all
to understand this part right here i've
seen sony clean a lot of dudes clocks
and i've also seen them get punched and
get knocked down but you know a lot of
sony dudes want to hold on to the fact
that
uh at the end of 360 when they moved on
we we came up we showed up shut up it
didn't matter then
so but i've seen people get
you know stumble and fall right what i'm
saying is
i don't like the footing that they're
placing themselves on
because if you're leveraging something
on tech that's not available
at an affordable cost worldwide to
everybody else because you're telling
people and this is this is where the
falsehood comes in because i said what
other falsehood did king talk about
there's a faucet that you could say that
you can use a regular drive
to put inside the playstation because
there is no regular drive that reaches
that spec facts factor
something to the effect like we'll let
you know what nvme
drives will be compatible exactly
currently nothing out right now that is
nothing
it's not there's no he according to him
right he said that
the relationship back and forth is fluid
meaning that the inf
that that things that they they do on
the console side will affect
the pc side right including in hardware
and i'm like i don't know about that
like
that's not how it works it's not how it
works like something that works on a
console specifically created for that
console
i doubt very much that all of a sudden
you're going to start seeing
you know regular hard drives nvme drives
on the on the pc
market would bust as fast and even if
they do
have that raw power speed right they're
not out yet though
they're coming out hopefully within the
holiday
time that's the and that's the question
is what's the price of these cards
but for both of them right right yeah
because one proprietary one's locking
you away from
any option whatsoever and one
like that's the one thing that i really
liked at the playstation conference
which was
hey listen we're going to allow you to
literally take
a a hard drive and put it into the
motherboard itself
right yeah they said we're going to
allow you to put
in a 600 hard drive to equal the same
price as your system
you don't know how much memory cards are
going to cost them right if you want to
do it i know it ain't going to cost
i know they're not going to cost 600.
we gotta be realistic here both the the
playstation 5 and the xbox series x
those memory cards are gonna get
uh generic knockoffs by other companies
uh you know that's gonna make the actual
people making them
have to compete with them so those
prices are going to come down
playstation it happens
every time i mean look at look at the
price of a controller right on
playstation
it's like
space over time will will dictate the
price of these cards and the more
so the hardware the hard drives and ssd
we have now
they were the same price three four
years ago
no because they made a lot of them no no
yes or no what are they the same price
here we go hold on anyway let me just
the matter is though it's not going to
have the same capabilities
that that internal hard drive is going
to have no matter what you do like even
today like we can't
nine times out of ten if you want
something to run at at its peak on an
xbox one a series
1x you put it on the internal drive
right even an external
sd for whatever reason in some instances
can't access stuff as fast as it would
just from the internal drive
so it's unreasonable to expect that
whatever you can purchase on open market
is going to compare to
what they built into the system and
that's why what mark cerny said is
it will be because you're plugging it
right into the board that's why
like the the the card that i have um or
the hard drive that i have plugged
right next to the cpu so it takes full
advantage
of the speed of that ssd so the ssd that
you're going to see
inside that playstation will probably be
the same type of ssd or it is it has to
be officially specced by playstation
yeah
before they can do it so we i'll get you
here let me jump we got two super chat
p call out gaming 5 super chat let's
face it when it comes to the playstation
5 versus xbox series x it's speed versus
power here they both will be unique in
their own way we can't fraud this it's
dope either way i salute you on that for
real for real
and we missed the first one uh salute to
the lords love what you all do continue
to spread the love and positive
wow yeah i missed that yeah we missed a
bunch we missed a bunch
we got to read them in order we can't
like order because no
i missed it i didn't see it i was
talking and arguing i was trying to
catch up continue
yeah dragon wolf with the two two pound
super chat uh will sony ssd do any
difference to cod madden et cetera
that's what i want yeah we got that one
we got that one i got the jd gamer did
we get the we got the pixel we need to
get the smitty schmidt i don't think we
can we got
did we get the pc devs uh final super
chat pc devs we're talking multiply
aren't going to unless pc also has that
hdd
on the other hand you write that one
okay
jim brian and you are i'm chris hart
reporting for
yo stop it disrespectful
okay listen man anyway
i'll jump in we've been super long and
this is going on i just want to say look
at the end of the day
super the super speed super saiyan ssd
you know i'm saying the joint sound fire
on paper
right sounds fire it sounds like they
won't be bottlenecked
as far as bandwidth this could be their
ace in the hole if it
says what they do does it that you know
it does it could be the essay
it's the whole i want to salute my boy
uh lord jean he's got a great article on
the 3d audio
sounds pretty revolutionary it seems
like they're going to try to leverage
that with vr
which is pretty cool you know they're
still sticking in that space i think
that 3d yeah it's for vr
yeah it feels feels like it's vr they're
talking about you know he's he's getting
your ears with me he wants your ears for
sale
so daniel's here is there so you get
those up in there
but what i will say like i said the
dislikes obviously you know you can't
bring that right after the the microsoft
thing so it felt like a clap back that
fell on his face like kind of what
batman said um and again i'm i'm gonna
be on them right
no benchmarks no real world
implementation you know
they did them no favors i think this is
the first time
in a long time that i can say
huge misstep by sony marketing-wise they
are generally the kings of marketing
they usually they i gotta give an l on
this one i've been very hard on
microsoft
over these this whole generation but
this is bad
and and my thing is you know at the end
of the day microsoft has to do this
stuff to prove
themselves to get people excited right
but if sony continues
this non-transparency you know what i'm
saying and not
you know giving implementations and
stuff like that
things turn you know i'm saying so again
yes when the games come
the games will matter overall i agree
playstation nation
but if you keep doing these kind of
moves
right now you could literally have the
most revolutionary thing in the game but
everybody thinks
that it's trash and everybody thinks
that but you know microsoft is
completely killing them so that's the
mistake right now marketing is a huge
deal
it's a huge deal so we don't want to
minimize that so
that's all i got we got a blaze through
like super fast takes on the last two so
we are late late late
oh man um yeah lord sorry you do do
about the animal we'll make it
we'll double this up man together yeah
so what do you feel about do maternal
two big releases yeah doom internal uh
they both came out the same day
uh what can i say man like i do maternal
is what you would call the chef's kiss
it's a moi it's it's one of those like
blue maternal
has taken uh
but i will say um everything that they
did to bring
doom back to the limelight with 2016 is
is turned up to
100 here um the game runs super smooth
60 frames per second
um it is they they call it what they
call it is combat chest right and it's a
marketing term right but it really does
describe this game
well what they did in doing 2016 was to
bring distill
what doom is which is fast combat
um gore and bring that
to the modern like to a modern game by
and then by taking the combat and
turning it into like sort of a mini game
unto itself that's what made it
different in addition to adding a jump
button which also made the movement that
much more crazy
in this game they take that combat chest
and take it to another level now
when you get into a combat scenario it
really is about
looking at the enemies you're facing and
how do you take them out most
efficiently
and able to get your
more uh more uh
health and able to get more um ammo and
able to get more
um uh what you would call it a shield
right
so every the way you attack people
depends
on what they drop right if you have
somebody with a with a glory kill
you're going to get health if you give
somebody with um
um what you will call it with a this new
thing you have it's called like a
freaking like a
a flame belch it turns everybody on fire
and they're able to give you shield
like so the way you approach the combat
determines
what you get in return and and
determines if you
if you're able to have enough health
enough shield
or enough uh ammo to last in a fight so
every single scenario is different and
people approach every single scenario
differently
so beyond that like in terms of the
combat they've made they've taken it up
to another level right in terms of the
look of the game the look the game is
hdr super fast 60 frames per second
the game looks absolutely fantastic on
all platforms the x looks absolutely
beautiful
um and just in terms of like the lore
and stuff like that look
you don't need doom lord doesn't really
matter right
at the same time no afghans they do
such a great job of with within the
campiness of what doom is
to to make you sort of it matters though
like they give a backstory to
to the doom slayer and like this this
this order of like
essentially gods that he comes from and
and him
sort of turning his back on them and
it's all very
campy tongue-in-cheek right you listen
you literally have
a a floating fortress in space that is
called
the what is it called the something of
doom right
the fortress of doom
it leans into the campiness in a way
that it fits doom so perfectly i
cannot blow weight enough about how much
i love this game
look they brought doom back yet again
they really killed it no no
it's not too uh not too gruesome
compared to some things i've played but
uh
i'm enjoying it the only thing i've
found wrong with it
and it's just a me problem i sound like
mooch just now
uh is the platforming i don't remember
this all the platforming in 2016 release
i feel like i spent more time jumping
and trying to get to an objective than i
do actually fighting in the in the game
yeah that's my only issue with it i
think
how far are you yet at this point will
me i took out the first
uh hell priest okay so
what happens is yes i agree with you
when it's the platforming just to get
from a to b
it slows it down right because you're
not in combat it's not not like you're
fighting people in the middle of combat
this is something they showed in in
preview videos and stuff like that but i
won't
mention it specifically there's a weapon
you get an upgrade that you get later on
that allows you to traverse while sort
of
also attacking in a way which makes the
the traversal part
more kinetic and related to the fight as
opposed to just getting from point a to
b
right and it makes that part a little
bit better but i do agree with you they
added it
and it's cool it doesn't necessarily
bother me too much but if you if you
want the constant like
fight to fight to fight to fight it
slows things down in a way that
you're not necessarily used to doom
doing right other games
it's good that it'll give you like a
brief respite from all the craziness
right
in doom that's kind of the point right
you kind of just want to be
almost overwhelmed all the time and this
it kind of it gives you that lull period
that doesn't seem like it really fits in
doom
but they sort of rectify it later on
when you get that upgrade it
it makes the moving around a lot faster
and it incorporates
fighting into it that's what's up bad
bit did you pick up doom
journals oh my god that's all i've been
playing right now guys
i love her so much she's so beautiful um
uh you know i i played doom 2016
literally
a week before playing this game um
i cannot go back to doom 2016. it's too
slow
start you off with some of the the
fundamentals
of movement that doom 2016 didn't have
like double jump
opens up the ways of fighting to not
really necessarily
fit your style but you're able to move
around the environment
so so much more fluidly than you were
before and so much more faster as well
that
the combat is frantic it's hectic it is
insane but at the same exact time and
challenging and at the same exact time
it still gives you that that that
complex that we often
that want right like that it gives you
kind of like that god complex
afterwards or the god of the the power
fantasy that that
video games often try to achieve that's
what doom eternal achieves
100 of the way you're being challenged
but every time you get through it you're
like yeah no those guys
they stood no they had absolutely no
chance
it's gorier it is more strategic
um and you're you're thinking on the fly
i would even call it chess it's chuckles
you're bouncing
when it comes to the platforming
elements to me
they're not the best but it is a good
way of breaking up from
constant fighting because if that was
the case
you just start getting a little bored
okay so they break it up through
platforming so that your brain is doing
something different different synapses
are firing
and you kind of get a break and then
they give you
they give you things like slayer gates
which are
absolutely insane just high levels of
difficulty
tossing any which enemy at you i am
god i would like to say about 15 hours
in
the game it's fantastic it is it is at
the end of the day i'm not even done
playing it
it's one of the greatest single-player
shooters i have yeah
no like really what they did with like
every single
area you go to looks vastly different
and one the one criticism of 2016 is
that everything sort of looks sort of
red and drab
and because you were you were literally
like in hell right
so now you're you're on earth and earth
has been destroyed by
by the minions it gives you like the
little 80s
like action movie type stuff like you
literally have the predator gun
on your shoulder firing grenades at
people like
there are little things that they try to
do to set up like
how an 80s action thing was set up and
then they just take that expectation
and they just throw it out but they give
you something even more amazing
like it's it is yeah
it's just okay
while 2016 felt repetitive towards the
end as much as i loved that game
this one constantly gives you something
new to look at
um and and again it's constantly
throwing new enemies at you
um different takes on older enemies it's
it's crazy
how how how much individual and sort of
like
different stuff they put throughout this
entire game
real quick before we walk on king and
attic did you pick it up if not
are you planning on picking it up okay
shout out to game pass i'm playing
uh 2016. um
yeah phil dominance maximum expensive
has allowed me to know that uh
when i'm finished this uh i'll be
playing the ones that y'all playing
when it comes to game pass no money
entry
i'm good addict uh dude
is this something interesting are you
excited do you go pick up look man
this this this this academic that we uh
you know people had to choose things man
you know
i had to choose between stuff and yeah
it was just like do i want to play dude
sure maybe
i don't know but you know i i i can't
justify
spending that money on it right now i
feel like yeah final fantasy around the
corner i know he's not
yeah y'all can throw me in the bushes on
this one too i really wanted to pick it
up soft but it's just
it's so much that came at the same time
and king might be on to something
because i foolishly ran out and got
doomed
first day and all this stuff and then
phil dominus decides to throw it in
gamepad i was so
pissed i was like i just spent the money
so my new thing with bethesda games is
i'm waiting
because they tend to fall into the laps
of game pass so put the game pass up
i'm waiting do you think it's coming
soon because 2016 is going to come
soon and it comes soon at the end of the
day listen my background is crazy
it's too much going on and as much as i
let it get a game look phenomenal i
i won't be able to justify enough time
playing to it so right now busy
buying hospital 2.0 yeah and
segue into my next topic
at the end of the day man you know if
someone comes across you know code you
can throw it to me but you know i won't
i won't say no to that but you know what
shout out to jake you gotta make some
choices
yeah he said dumatron will come to gay
pass for xbox series x launch call now
i'm if you're on something cause that's
what i'm hoping
none of these frauds in here played it i
don't know bad bit did you
pick up animal crossing a little bit
okay okay
so i'll make it brief and painless for
the rest because i know they're waiting
for me to stop talking about this
look man first animal crossing game
never played one before
you know shout out to here's the fraud
light on me for what oh my god
when it comes to this game you just
purchased it because it's a big nintendo
title
and it's you know it doesn't matter what
it said it could be
donkey spit i'm getting a new donkey
spit for the switch
that's perfectly fine we got to be
realistic here okay
i'm going to keep the fraud alert up for
this whole topic wow
he said this is when everybody the chat
goes away
at the end of the day if playstation or
microsoft made a game that looked like
this no one would have booted
so we got to see what it's about so i
will make my topic very quickly you can
talk while this front alerts going let
it ride let it ride baby
let let the beat go around on the floor
let's get some fraud alerts in the trap
for lord cause that's right put it on
you throw it up throw your frauds up
anyway so what i gotta say yo never
played one before
we went to pax and i'm gonna tell y'all
right now i have no
bad bit you could co-sign that was out i
have never seen
the most cult-like mind-following of
people
with this game i've never seen a game
like i was hearing people doing
gregorian chants i was like what is
going on in this section
of the conference i swear to god they
brought
i think his name's k.k slider yeah
the dog of the banjo i heard
one person go kk and everybody just
just ran towards this pool yes
[Music]
why are people going crazy about this
stupid little bear
what is going on with this dude that was
chasing the little boy what's this
why are you running why are you running
i must have this game i need to know
what is this about
yo it's hilarious y'all it is funny and
you know what's funny yo i go front yo
bad [ __ ]
just the way they talk to each other
with that sound
i'll be on the floor
wait a second they don't even got voice
let's get that boy let's wrap this up
this no longer deserves the fraud it
deserves it into the bushes alert okay
it's going into the bushes yo it is
hilarious bro i'm making my little
island they flew me out there i got that
called my island the realm
i'm out there making my little giant i
gotta go shop gotta do stuff yo it's
it's i will say that it is the most
relaxing hilarious game i've ever played
anything like this
get give me a percentage how many days
gotta go by before we never hear this
game again
look i'm done cause they they hate know
me they hate them but yo
i will say this man i've never played
what i i'm starting to understand the
appeal
it is very addicting he's gonna
understand it until about two days that
he ain't never listen
i told you i was gonna throw it up three
months three months from now king
you know we haven't really got a game
since animal crossing he gonna forget he
even played
you owe me pocket watching look at
disney y'all pocket watching my
enjoyment
yo come on slovo i don't get it the game
is [ __ ] come on slow mo not like
not even saying the game is trash it
looks interesting but i'm saying that
all these people ain't never played this
game so it came out on the switch
who's driving to cog's house to do the
intervention later
oh man you playing that game and they
doing that
the fraud alert i'm not going to
throttle it myself okay
oh my god so don't do that man don't do
that we'll get copyrighted by
unbelievable believable
[Laughter]
tech spec reveals of both the xbox
series x and the playstation 5 this past
week
which tech features do you think will be
most important the choices are
a 12 teraflops dx12 ultimate
full rdna 2.0 for that series
x choices b the next generation of ssd
variable clocks and 3d audio that ps5
or c i don't care until we get that
digital foundry
by side comparison smoke
do something christmas please rock the
phone it goes up on iop
twitter shout out to lord will be
hood in the realm making his debut
fantastic gaming history one of the most
put some shields in that chat for wilmy
put some [ __ ] put some shields in the
chat for love will me hood man an
outstanding story listen it's video game
history one of the most chattable guys
in the realm
humble beginnings to see where he's come
to listen to his journey was truly
inspiring
please lord will me hood the realm wants
to know where the people can find you
and what you have going on man uh you
can find me just about anywhere of
course as you know you can find me on
twitter
uh xbox playstation switch unsadly
epic on epic stores steam i mean you can
find me anywhere man just type in will
be hood
you can find me every wednesday night at
of course will be hood on youtube
at maybe beyond the box yes salute do we
still do we still do a horror cast is
that
going on or we kind of slow down
whenever we try to do it on sunday
evenings but there really hasn't been a
lot to talk about lately
i feel you i feel you so we'd rather not
do the show if we don't have any
any content no doubt shout out your team
man great team
[ __ ] nation man shout out to t
all the time he's always on twitch but
right now the guy's so busy at work
because you guys know he works at the or
he just doesn't have time to stream no
doubt man salute keep
keep it up about again catch wilmi's
game and beyond the box a lot of fun a
lot of humor
really positive stuff in the community
always salute this brother man it was
great to finally have you in the realm
lord bad bit from the trophy room
podcast coming
in to salute and rep that sony blue
looking very sweet
disney wants the shirts by the way this
is all about the shirts
they're coming soon uh you can find me
over at bad big games where you're
talking about all game news reviews
and where i'll be unboxing this bad boy
tomorrow
all right should we joined the pc master
race
that's what happens i heard and yeah you
can join me over at the trophy room a
playstation podcast made by the players
for the players
each and every thursday but this week
wednesday
me my best friend kyle will be live on
youtube at bad big games
or who would have ninja 73 or itunes or
google play or spotify wherever you get
your rss feeds
and please raise your stars you leave
this off the show and that's where you
can find me
oh good brother always a pleasure to
have you in the room talking that sony
talk
you know what i'm saying and of course
lord in the realm
firing back shooting this dart hating on
animal crossing where can i find people
fighting
watch out now so you can uh definitely
follow me on twitter at uh
lord addict iop no no no no no let's do
that over
mommy gotta do it all right yeah i'm
kind of quick on that too twitter
yeah twitter at uh
you know definitely want to thank
everyone for coming out here you know
it's been a it's been an
amazing show it's definitely been a
longer show than we normally do
uh you know but you know one thing i
want to point out is that as you can see
cognito has all that merchandise you
know
go and stand up show them to show them
the lord's a gaming shirt you can find
all of that right there at our uh you
know at teespring
get all the merchandise and you know i
wanted to bring up real quick before we
end this
this is what cognito is is is riding and
dying
this is animal crossing who is playing
this
like come on shout out to the millions
of millions put the business up in the
chat for the mpd that's going to come
out on your neck with it you know i'm
gonna do that topic yeah i know i'm
gonna do that talk so y'all can talk
cause i'm but i'm going to do that topic
when that next month come out
the game's bad i'm just saying that
came out the same day
right now let's go you know we
we here at the you know the lords we we
do have a website you can definitely go
hit that website up
it's in this it's in the chat to go
check out our reviews opinion pieces
until we see you next week yeah man you
already know and of course lord sort of
returning back on the book of acts the
book of acts
and the book i'm going to fight with the
lords i want that to be our next logo
we get 10 more subs until about
subscribers to the realm we get both
his return always good to have him back
in the room and there's so much going on
in the world lord sav where can the five
people find you what you got going on
sir
uh you can definitely find me at bx
sovereign on psn xbox live and lawyer
iop on twitter and then uh
because of the ways of the world i mean
man
you can't spit it like you can't put
them back do it like you
that's why i had to remind you to do it
right shots fired
shots but if you don't use it i'm going
to be local so you use this
steal it but yeah man uh that's it man
because of the ways of the world i might
have some more time to play a little bit
anyway
so you might be will you be on our
community game baser
when is that day we're having a
community day with the lord
we would like all the lords to be a part
of it
is not playing nothing until he finishes
my game i want to play something fun for
all of us to play i think
that you know gta 5 heist or array
we could play sea of thieves where we
could all do a [ __ ] i think
that would be fun i play safety all i'm
going to do is go to the brink and drink
i'm just or we can play state of decay
because
you know i want to go i'm going to ask
him i want to go play
you play warzone
put in the chat which you guys like the
lords of play and put in the comments
section which you guys want the lords to
play and i'll look through there
you know get get on there and i'll use
that community tab thing that caught you
needs to happen y'all need to have it
but yeah so that that's it would you
what you've been playing as far as um
whether people can find you all that
good stuff
yeah i did that already we're good we
could you can find me online maybe
maybe maybe online profile okay lord
king back in the world spitting them
bars
on the magician's neck
where did the father find you
doing his parlor tricks
you can catch me at lords of gaming.net
with the new uh
kos i got something special for you guys
next week
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's end this before i go home
yeah definitely uh you can catch me uh
well there's no boxing there's no sports
right now but um
you know what we do is we do have old
classics so i might be doing some old
classics on some kos
giving you my fight predictions
[Laughter]
with knowing the results um i could be a
hundred percent right
a couple weeks ago it's like you knew
the result of that boxing match a couple
weeks ago oh yeah definitely yeah
all right peter uh roger mayweather uh
oh yes
oh boy that was a sad one because
you know that's a bad one um yeah
agree okay well you know guys
[ __ ] turn because i stopped talking it's
like it's time to go look remember
y'all already know look everybody salute
that came through fantastic show shout
out to
me again shout out i'm sorry sorry i'm
sorry sorry sorry a shout out to will me
hood
shout out to uh bad bit bad [ __ ] my boy
from boston
uh we got a chance to take a picture
with the brother uh um let me tell you
something
uh he's out here in these streets he
goes um please go
and check out his uh the trophy room um
the guy's a hard worker he's he yo
he was definitely there and
it warms my heart to meet people that we
we talked to
yeah stuff like that and you know
genuine nice dude
i wish we got a chance to hang out more
but you know we got that working
everybody's working
god bless yeah salute man again again
slow moving
salute baby what happened yeah i'm just
like first off uh when i
because i was wanting to do the slander
on a uh on
what's that animal crossing i already
got the name i forgot you know
definitely thank you for
you know the guests coming on i do want
to say something real quick i've what
i'm going to go ahead and do
is i'm going to put the community post
for the members to choose the games
and then i'm going to get four from all
the members and then i'm gonna put that
on twitter and let the community choose
between those four games
yeah absolutely man absolutely
definitely got to do it all for the
lords
including sav including
[Laughter]
you have to get that bubble but yeah
again the chad was outstanding wilmy was
outstanding
please uh nuke you missed it so get the
beginning of the show
again lords gaming.net y'all moving and
grooving a lot of content up there right
now please check out the articles y'all
really
really appreciate the support when you
retreat y'all share we got a ton of
stuff coming this week
also special announcement next week
sunday will be a special guest hopefully
huge so please stay tuned
a couple days so we'll we'll do i know
but i got to do it thursday
you'll get that no saturdays when we do
the promo right saturday we do
get that saturday we'll give you the
promo it's going to be one great show
because it should be an epic show please
tune in next sunday that's all i got
everybody man glad to give you guys last
oh shout out and i got to give a super
shout out to for the first time
shout out to smitty smith the book of
hashtag you won today brother you don't
say jonathan b boss booze you got to get
over your game because
this business out here in these streets
everybody enjoyed it sunday we are out
of here
hit that intro attic peace
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
you